أنت ما تبغى تكون في هذا الموضع
ليش تحط نفسك في موضع شيء أنت بالنسبة له نملة؟
وأهدافكم متعارضة
يمكن ما يبغى يبيدك عشان بس يبغى يبيدك
بس مو أهدافه أهدافي؟
هذه هي النقطة
يعني هل هو يقدر يفكر لحاله بدوني؟
أنا في الأخير اللي بضغط إدخال
وبدون ما أضغط إدخال؛ هو مو بجالس يسوي شيء
قلل عدد الوفيات البشرية
عندك مانع أنه يكتبها؟
أبد
اضغط إدخال؟
اضغط إدخال
تكتشف أنه بيقوم وبيحاول يذبح كل البشر
تعطيه هدف صريح، زين وللا لا
بيلقى ثغرات
وإذا لغى ثغرة أنت ما انتبهت لها
ما في عودة
مو معناه أنك أنت بنيت الشيء
معناه أنك عندك قدرة على التحكم عليه
أي واحد عنده عيال؛ بيعرف
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
في هذه الحلقة
يؤكد ضيفي تأكيدًا لا يدع مجالًا للشك
أن الآلة ستتفوق على الإنسان
ستهزم البشرية
وأنها مُهدد حقيقي للوجود البشري
ويتفق على هذا الطرح طبعًا علماء وباحثين كُثر
فحبيت نتكلم عن الذكاء الاصطناعي بشكل موسّع
والصراحة، أني أطمح إلى تكثيف الطرح
في هذا المجال من زوايا متعددة
لعل المعرفة هذه تساعدنا في فهم المستقبل
ومن يدري؛ ممكن أحد يقدر يعدّل في مسار هلاكنا
ضيفي في هذه الحلقة الدكتور «إبراهيم المسلّم»
هو أستاذ في الذكاء الاصطناعي من جامعة «أكسفورد»
وهو من المطالبين بحوكمة الذكاء الاصطناعي والسيطرة عليه
أيش الجهود اللي تقوم فيها الحكومات اليوم للسيطرة عليه؟
وين وصلنا؟
هل مثلًا نتعامل معه مثل تعاملنا مع المفاعلات والقنابل النووية؟
والحقيقة أن فيه أسئلة كثيرة
في محاولة لفهم ذكاء الآلة ومستقبلها
حيث أن الأذكى؛ بيسيطر على الآخر قطعًا
يقول أبو أحمد: أن الآلة أذكى لا محالة
قبل أن نبدأ
إذا كنت مهتم بسماع حلقات فنجان أول ما تنزل
وما ودك يفوتك شيء منها
تابع فنجان، وفعّل إشعاراته في منصات البودكاست
وراح أحط الرابط في وصف الحلقة
مع العلم أن موعد نشر الحلقة الصوتية
هو الساعة ستة صباحًا كل يوم أحد
والمرئية الساعة 6:00 مساءً كل يوم أربعاء
ثلاثة أيام من نشر الصوتية
أما الآن، لنبدأ
من المتشائمين وللا من المتفائلين بالذكاء الاصطناعي؟
أنا من...
أتذكرك الحلقة الأولى كنت متشائم
ماني متشائم
يا أخي فيه فرق، بين لما أقول لك
هل تتوقع...
لو أسألك عبدالرحمن مثلًا
هل ممكن تموت من حادث السيارة لا قدر الله؟
ممكن
هل مثلًا أمشي وأقول
عبدالرحمن يتوقع أنه بيموت بحادث سيارة؟
متشائم
فيه فرق لما يقولك شيء ممكن، وخلنا نحترز له
اربط احزام. حط حساباتك
وبين أني أقول هذا توقعي
أنا ماني متشائم
أنا أقول: إذا الوضع استمر على ما هو عليه؛ فأنا متشائم
بس أنا متفائل أن الوضع ما راح يستمر
طيب، قبل شوي واحنا كذا نتناقش
نقاش حاد
تمام
على الذكاء الاصطناعي
فأحس أن أغلب الناس يشوفون الذكاء الاصطناعي هو...
لما الناس تقول أنه خطر الذكاء الاصطناعي فيما بعد
يربط على أيش جالس يشوفه اليوم من الذكاء الاصطناعي
صحيح
تمام، بس...
هو شوف أنت...
حتى تكلمنا فيها المرة الماضية
فيه مستويات للذكاء الاصطناعي
اللي هو ضعيف والقوي والخارق
لما نتكلم عن الذكاء الاصطناعي
اللي ممكن يتفوق على ذكاء البشر
هذا على قولتهم يصنف خطر وجودي
وهذا ممكن؟ أنه نوصل له يعني؟
نحن في الطريق للوصول له؟
ما في أي مانع
لو تشوف تاريخ التقنية
ماشيين في رتم متصاعد
ما في شيء يمنع
ما في شيء تقدر تثبت أنك ما تقدر تتخطى ذكاء الإنسان
يعني ما في كذا واحد فيزيائي
يحاول بناء مركبة تمشي أسرع من سرعة الضوء
لأني أقدر أثبت لك إياه على الورقة، انسَ الموضوع
ما أقدر أنزل مثلًا تحت الصفر كلفن
فيه أشياء مستحيلة فيزيائيًّا
لأن الفيزيائيين ما يحاولون
حلو وللا لا؟
لو نرتب ذكاءات الكائنات مثلًا
من أميبا، حشرات، حيوانات، إنسان
هل احنا الحد الأقصى؟
ما في شيء يقول إيه وللا لا
الناس ماشيين على أساس أنه ممكن
واو!
إيه
طيب أصلًا أيش هو الذكاء؟
عشان لما نقول الذكاء الاصطناعي
خلينا نعرف، متى يصير الإنسان ذكي؟
شوف أول شيء، نعرف عن الذكاء أنه نسبي
يعني ما تقدر على شيء ذكي أو غبي
إلا لما تعرف الهدف
بمعنى، تخيل أنك مثلًا طالع
شفتني كذا قاعد أكسر سيارتي
تقول أيش التصرف ذا الغبي؟
وبعدين تكتشف مثلًا ولدي محبوس جوّا، وأبغى أنقذه
وما في وقت مثلًا أدور مفتاح وللا...
بتقول تمام في السياق هذا؛ لا التصرف ذكي
فهمت علي؟
وبرضه من الحكم في قصة نوح مثلًا
أنه كيف واحد يقعد يبني سفينة في صحراء
بس لما تعرف الهدف ولما تعرف السياق
قصة موسى مع الخضر
لما عرف السياق؛ بان أنه تصرف ذكي
فأحيانًا فيه تصرف قد يبدو لك ذكي
لما تعرف الهدف؛ يطلع غبي
والعكس، تصرف قد يبدو غبي
لكن لما تعرف الهدف؛ يبدو ذكي
توّي كنت ألعب مع «تركي» شطرنج
خلنا نضرب فيه مثال
تخيل أنك جيت كذا، لقيتني قاعد ألعب شطرنج
ولعبت لعبة كذا قد تبدو غبية
مثلًا وزيري كذا، واضح أنه بينوكل
فجيت قلت: أيش اللعبة دي يا أبو أحمد؟
واضح أنه بينوكل
بعدين تكتشف، أني مثلًا ألعب مع ولدي
وبس ترى الموضوع مو ...
حبيت أكوّن علاقة معه، وحتى لو انهزمت؛ بيتعلم
فجأة، صارت اللعبة الغبية هذه في سياق هذا أنه ذكي
والعكس، لو لعبت لعبة كذا
قلت: يا إبراهيم، أيش دي الحركة البطلة؟
بعدين تكتشف أني قاعد ألعب مع ولد أخوي عمره ثلاث سنين
تقول يا...
لا، وأبغى أعلمه
ففي السياق هذا، الحركة هذه غبية؛ قياسًا على الهدف
ما تقدر تقول تصرف ذكي وللا غبي
هو نسبةً إلى هدف
عادة الناس تقول هذا تصرف ذكي وللا غبي
تلقاه يقيس على أهدافه هو
بس الأهداف هنا مشكلة
ترى ما في شيء اسمه هدف ذكي وهدف غبي
الهدف هدف
مثل المسلّمات في الرياضيات
يعني مثل في الرياضيات الحين
أنا أقدر مثلًا أبدا لك من نظرية، وأبدا أستنتج لك
مثلًا أقولك: ألف إذن باء، باء إذن جيم، جيم إذن دال إلى ياء
ياء؛ المسلّمات
تسأل الرياضي يقولك
والله المسلّمات احنا بادين فيها، هي مسلمات
مثلًا خطين متوازيين يتقاطعون
أقصر مسافة بين نقطتي خط مستقيم
فالمسلّمات هذه خلاص
أنت أهم شيء أن ما يكون عندك تعارض
لكن فيه شروط على المسلّمات
بس ما خلونا ندخل فيها
نفس الكلام الأهداف
ما تقدر تقول على...
فيه نقطة معينة؛ ما تقدر تقول الهدف هدف
يعني نرجع لمثال الشطرنج
لو سألتني مثلًا، قلت: إبراهيم ليش تبغى تنهزم؟
أقولك مثلًا: أبغى ولدي يتعلم
تقول لي: ليش تبغاه يتعلّم؟
أقول لك: أبغاه يطوّر مهاراته
تقول لي: ليش تبغاه يطوّر مهاراته؟
أقول لك: أبغاه ينجح في الحياة
تقول لي: ليش تبغاه ينجح في الحياة؟
أقول لك: أبغاه يصير سعيد
تقول: ليه؟ أقول: خلاص عاد، ولدي أحبه
يعني فيه حد بقولك هي كذا
فهذه مثل المسلّمات في الرياضيات
فهذه المسلّمة اللي...
فهذه يسمونها أهداف وسيطة
وهذه يسمونها أهداف نهائية
الأهداف الوسيطة ترى ممكن تتغيّر
ممكن مثلًا لو جاء ولدي قال
يُبا أنا ما لي في الشطرنج والأمور هذه
أنا لقيت نفسي أكتر في الرياضة، وللا كذا
أقول: تمام، كان ودي، بس الله يوفقك
مثلًا وإلا لقيت نفسي في التجارة
يلا، كم تبغى تحرق من فلوسي؟ خذ
شوف إذا كان الهدف يتغيّر
فهو مو بهدف، هو وسيلة
بس ما في شيء في الدنيا
يخليني آخذ حبة؛ وتخليني أكره عيالي
تقول: خذ إبراهيم هذه حبة
وخلاص، تكره عيالك وترتاح. ولا تشيل همهم
حتى لو ذبحتهم؛ القانون ما راح يحاسبك
ما في شيء يخليني أغيّر هدفي النهاية هذا
بالعكس لو بتجبرني؛ ممكن أعاركك
فهذه التصرفات تقدر تقيسها على الأهداف
والأهداف فيه أشياء وسيطة، وفي أهداف نهائية
الأهداف النهائية ما تتغيّر
والأهداف ولا تقدر...
في المجال فيه نظرية اسمها «نظرية التعامد»
تقول لك: أنه ما تقدر تستنتج الأهداف من الذكاء
يعني ممكن تكون مرة ذكي؛ وعندك هدف سخيف
وللا تكون عندك أهداف معقدة
ويكون ذكائك متوسط
فما فيه علاقة بين الأهداف والذكاء
يعني ما تقدر تستنتج الهدف من الذكاء
ولا الذكاء من الهدف
خليني بعطيك مثال
تخيل أقول لك مثلًا
أيش لون سيارتي إذا كان اليوم الأحد؟
بالضبط، هذا التعامد في الرياضيات
يعني الذكاء ما يعلّمك أي شيء عن الأهداف
والأهداف ما تعلمك أي شيء عن الذكاء
متى نقول...
لا لا ، أبد بالعكس
متى نقول على هدف ذكي؟
وللا متى يصير الشيء ذكي؟
متى الإنسان يكون ذكي
عشان إذا عرفت إن هذا الشيء ذكي
فهل هو تحقيق الأهداف؟ هل هو...؟
أيش بالضبط اللي يخلي هذا الشيء ذكي؟
عشان أعرف كيف خليت ذكاء اصطناعي؟
كما ما قلت لك
ما تقدر تقول على شيء ذكي أو غبي
إلا لما تعرف الهدف
ممتاز
الآن كيف تعرف أن هذا الشيء ذكي وللا لا؟
تكتشف بقياسه على هدفه
هذا على قولتهم يعني...
اللي واجهوه العلماء قبل
وكان فيه تعاريف كثيرة، والفلاسفة كل واحد عنده نظرته
بعدين جاء «آلن تورينق»
اللي هو مؤسس علم الحاسب هذا
«أينشتاين» حقنا
وقال: شوف، لو أسأل مئة واحد عن تعريف الذكاء
يمكن يجيني مئة تعريف
بس لو أسأل مئة واحد هل الإنسان ذكي؟
كان فيه إجماع أن الإنسان ذكي
فقال: ليش ما نحوّل التعريف إلى اختبار؟
وبدل ما أحاول أعرّف الذكاء الاصطناعي
خلني أحاول أتعرف عليه عن طريق الاختبار هذا
فالاختبار بسيط
أنه أنا بحاور شيء، أنا ما أدري هو آلة أو إنسان
إذا ما قدرت أميّز
هل أنا أتحاور مع آلة أو إنسان، أو ما قدرت أفرّق
فـ«آلن تورينق» يقول: إذا ما قدرت تفرّق؛ فما في فرق
فهذا تقدر تقول أنها طريقة تقدر تقيس فيها الذكاء
بس أنت أخذت الإنسان هو كالمعيار
وهذه يسمونها «المدرسة السلوكية» في الذكاء الاصطناعي
تعريف الذكاء هو سلوك معين
إذا أنت عندك السلوك هذا
خلاص معناته أنت تصنف ذكي
جاء فيلسوف ثاني اسمه «جون سيرب»
أعترض على نظرة «تورينق»
وطرح حُجة اسمها حُجة «الغرفة الصينية»
قال: تخيل فيه واحد، في غرفة مثل اللي احنا فيها الحين
وفيها كل الكتب اللي يحتاجها
والتعليمات اللي يحتاجها عشان يترجم أي جملة
من الإنقليزي إلى اللغة الصينية
الغرفة هذه تدخّل عليه أنت بس ورقة
مكتوب فيها جمل بالغة الإنقليزية
وهو يتبع التعليمات، ويطلعها من الجهة الثانية مترجمة
فـ«سيرب» سأل قال
هل الشخص هذا فاهم اللغة الصينية؟
بس مجرد يتبع تعليماته
اللي هو تشبيه للحاسب، الحاسب يتبع تعليمات
فتعريف «سيرب» للذكاء
أنه لا، هو مو مجموعة تصرفات
هو كيفية مو فقط ظاهرة
كيف تفكر لها علاقة؟
طبعًا فيه ناس ردوا عليه
قال: طيب نفس الكلام، مخك أنت الحين
ما في منطقة معينة تعرف الصينية، وللا تعرف الإنقليزية
مخك كامل، فالغرفة كاملة تعرف الصيني
وكل الثنتين هذولي مقياس الإنسان
فيه ناس يقول: لا، المقياس عاد الإنسان
ممكن يقول أشياء أو تطلع منه تصرفات غبية
مع احترامي الشديد
بالطبع فيه ناس أذكياء، وفيه ناس أغبياء
فقالوا: لا، فيه اللي يتصرف بعقلانية
أو اللي مثلًا يفكر بعقلانية
فهذه تقريبًا تقدر تقول أربعة
يعني سلوكية وتفكير
معيار الإنسان ومعيار المنطق
واليوم يوم نشوف الذكاء الاصطناعي
ما مدى تشابهه مع الذكاء الإنساني؟
وين قصوره حتى مقابل ذكاء الإنسان؟
اللي اليوم احنا وصلنا له
شوف، احنا مو بقاعدين نحاول...
احنا استوحينا من المخ
بس مو كأنه مثله بالضبط
كيف أشبهها؟
يعني مثل الفرق بين تصميم الطيارة، وكيف العصفور يطير
فيه الفكرة العامة
بس خلاص تطور بمسار مختلف تمامًا
فعندنا في الآلة هذا التشابه
فهم حاولوا أنه عندنا...
خليها على سبيل الإنسان
أيش فيه شيء ثاني حاولوا يشابهونه
عشان يوصل إلى الذكاء الاصطناعي اليوم؟
حاولوا بالخوارزميات التطورية مثلًا
يعني مو على مستوى المخ
على مستوى البيولوجي البياني، يعني تطور بيولوجي
ونفس الكلام قالوا
تمام، الآن التطور فيه اصطفاء طبيعي
وفيه طفرة جينية وفيه تزاوج
بعدين فيه الجيل يكون أكثر كفاءة
ففي خوارزمية تطورية، أيش فكرتها؟
فكرتها أنك تبدأ بحلول عشوائية
ونفس التطور؛ البقاء للأقوى
يعني ممكن في البداية الحلول عشوائية
كلها تجيب لك نتائج سيئة
بس هذا نتيجته أفضل من هذا بشوي
وهذا نتيجته أفضل من هذا بشوي
فاحتمال أن هذولي ينجون للجيل اللي بعده؛ أعلى
وبعدين يدمجون الحلين
وتستمر، وتسوي طفرات جينية عشوائية مع الوقت
إلى أن تلقى التسلسل هذا جيل عن جيل
معدل الدقة يزيد
نضرب مثال الشطرنج مرة ثانية
مثل فيه لغز يسمونه «المشاكل الثمانية للملكة»
اللي هو عندك رقعة شطرنج
وكيف أني أحط ثمان وزراء
بحيث ما حد يهجم على الثاني
حاول تسويها، صعبة شوي
فتقعد تحلها بخوارزمية تطورية
تجي تقول: بالبداية أحطهم أماكن عشوائية، حلو؟
وسوّ ألف مرة
وبعدين تشوف مين اللي فيهم أقل تعارض
مثلًا في الترتيب هذا
حصل أن فيه عشرة وزراء يهجمون على بعض
والترتيب هذا فيه ثمانية
فهنا الثمانية مثلًا قدرته على النجاة أعلى
وبعدين الجيل الثاني، تاخذ اللي ثمانية وسبعة
وبعدين تقسم الرقعة نصفين وتدمج الحلين، وتستمر
وبعدين تسوي طفرة عشوائية
تحرّك وزير عشوائي
فهذا برضه الطريقة الثانية الاستيحاء من الطبيعة
متى أول مرة كذا وقفت
وأذهلك وصول الذكاء الاصطناعي إلى اليوم؟
والله «شات جي بي تي» صراحة
أي نسخة؟
أربعة
أربعة؟
أربعة صراحة مخيف
شوف ما أقولك ما كنت أتوقع يوصل الذكاء الاصطناعي
يوم من الأيام إلى هذا المستوى
بس أني اليوم أجلس معك في 2023
وهذا الذكاء الاصطناعي «شات جي بي تي 4» موجود
هذا ما كنت أتوقعه صراحة
يعني كنت أتوقع بنوصل هذا يمكن 2030 أو شيء مثل كذا
كنا ماشيين في التطور، بعدين فيه قفزة صارت
أيش اللي خلّى القفزة تصير بهذه السرعة؟
لأن اللغة من أصعب التحديات في الذكاء الاصطناعي
أوه!
إيه. حتى لاحظ اللغة سِمة بشرية
من كل الحيوانات الموجودة
يعني كل الحيوانات مثلًا عندها أبصار، وتشوف وتسمع
بس سمة اللغة والتواصل
وأنه فيه فكرة برأسي أوصلها لرأسك
عن طريق اللغة
ما هي موجودة في الحيوانات
أو على الأقل بهذا المستوى
اللغة بعد فيها تحدي خاص
لأنه على عكس مثلًا الصور والصوت
هو في النهاية الذكاء الاصطناعي تعطيه مدخلات
يحاول يتنبّئ ويطلّع لك مخرجات
صورة أو صوت هي عبارة عن مجموعة أرقام
يعني لو أعطيك صورة
هي مجموعة «بكسلز»
وكل بكسل مرقّم من 0 إلى 100
صفر أسود، ومئة أبيض
إذا افترضنا الصورة أبيض وأسود
ونفس الكلام الصوت
الصوت لو تتخيلها كذا كأنها مثل الملاحظة الصوتية
اللي في كل وقت فيه علو للصوت
الأرقام سهل التعامل معها
في الصور تقدر بطريقة سهلة
مثلًا أفصل لك صور النهار عن الليل
من البيانات اللي فيها
أقدر مثلًا بالصور...
كآلة أنت تتكلم الحين
إيه، كآلة
حتى طرق قديمة، في الصوت أقدر أفصل لك...
مثلًا أحلل الصوت إلى ترددات
وعادةً لأن الرجال تردده أقل من تردد صوت المرأة
فأقدر أفصل لك صوت الذكور على الإناث
بطرق بسيطة
لأنها موجودة بالطبع على صيغة أرقام
سهلة الهضم بالنسبة للكمبيوتر شوي
ولو أنه مو بهذه السهولة
اللغة مشكلتها أنه حروف كتابة، ما تقدر...
أعطيك مثال
كلمة مثلًا طبيب وبطارية ومستشفى
حلو
طبيب وبطارية، فيها أحرف متشابهة أكثر من كلمة مستشفى
صحيح
صح وللا لا؟
مع أنه يمكن كلمة طبيب أقرب لمستشفى بالمعنى
صحيح
فهي رمزية ما هي أرقام
وهذه أول مشكلة
كيف أحوّل مجموعة الرموز هذه إلى أرقام
يقدر يتعامل معها الآلة؟
فهذا أول تحدي
وكيف حلّوه هذا التحدي؟
ندخل شوي فيها
حاولوا يحولون كل كلمة إلى أرقام
تقدر تتخيلها كأنها اللوحة الأم ولها باركود
أنت لما تدخل السوبرماركت
وتشتري مثلًا تفاح وللا برتقال وللا قهوة
كل شيء عليه باركود
صح
بس إذا تأخذ باركود حق التفاح وتغيّر خط واحد
يمكن فجأة يطلع لك قهوة
وللا تغيّر خط واحد في القهوة
فجأة يطلع لك لبن، وللا...
ما لهم علاقة ببعض
الفكرة كيف أني أقدر أسوي مثلًا باركود
بحيث أني لو أغيّر خط في التفاح الأحمر
طلع لي تفاح أخضر
أبغى شيء قريب
أيش تسوي؟
تجيب أقرب اثنين لبعض
مثلًا تفاح أحمر وتفاح أخضر
عنب أحمر وعنب أخضر، برتقال ويوسف أفندي
وقسمهم اثنين اثنين
وتقول هذا خط وهذا خطين
وبعدين تعامل كل مجموعة كأنها شيء واحد
حلو
تقول: تمام، أيش أقرب؟
مثلًا التفاحتين والبرتقالتين أقرب لبعض
من مثلًا القهوة والشاهي
فتقول: زيد خط هنا وخط هنا
فلما تنتهي؛ تصير عندك كأنها مثل الشجرة تقريبًا
مو هذا بالضبط اللي يصير؛ بس هي نفس الفكرة
أني كيف أعطي كل كلمة باركود
بحيث أني لو أغيّر رقم
أو أغيّر شيء بسيط
على الأقل يطلع لي كلمة قريبة بالمعنى
كيف سوّوها في اللغة؟
مقياس التشابه خلّوه مقياس السياق
ليش مثلًا كلمة الأحد تشبه يوم الاثنين؟
لأني لما أقول مثلًا قابلت عبدالرحمن يوم «الـ»
تتوقع الأحد، الاثنين، الثلاثاء، الأربعاء
يعني إحصائيًّا احتمال ظهور الكلمات هذه
بعد قابلت فلان يوم «الـ»
أعلى من مثلًا كرسي، كاميرا
صح
صح وللا لا؟ وهو منطقيًّا
وهذا اللي نشوفه في لوحة المفاتيح في الجوال
لما أنا أكتب، صح؟
إيه بالضبط، هو يأخذ السياق يمكن الكلمة اللي قبل
لما تكتب: السلام، على الأرجح بتكتب بعدها: عليكم، صح؟
بالضبط، صحيح
هذه اللي استخدموها عشان يرتبون الكلمات جنب بعض
ويطلعون بباركود لكل كلمة
بس أن الآلة اللي ترتب وللا لا؟
الآلة هي اللي تحاول تستكشف...
يعني ما في أحد راح كتب: السلام
وقال لهم بعدها الاحتمال بيكون: عليكم
وهو الآلة لحالها اكتشفت أنه عليكم، صح؟
إيه الآلة اكتشفت من نفسها
بس شلون؟
بس أنت أعطيها البيانات
ليش الشركات قاعدة تجمع كل البيانات
وتسحب من الإنترنت؟
عشان تطلع بالإحصائيات هذه
تقول: عندك هذا الكم الهائل من البيانات
شوف أيش أكثر احتمال بعد كلمة السلام
وأيش هي أكثر كلمة بعد مثلًا
المملكة العربية، السعودية
فمنها يحاول يستخرج باركود لكل كلمة
بحيث إذا كانوا الباركود يتشابهون
فهم إحصائيًّا يتشابهون، فهمت عليه؟
ومن الأشياء اللي لاحظوها بعدين
لما انتهى الذكاء الاصطناعي من التدريب
لو تجيب الباركود حق كلمة «ملك»
بعدين تطرح منها كلمة ذكر
بعدين تجمع كلمة أنثى
يطلع لك الباركود حقت «ملكة»
قول ثاني
جيب الباركود حق كلمة «ملك»
حلو
بعدين اطرح منها، لأنها صارت أرقام الحين
صح
هي الفكرة كلها أني أنا بحوّل هذه الرموز
وهذه الخطوط إلى أرقام
عشان يقدر يهضمها الكمبيوتر
فالباركود حق «ملك» اطرح منه الباركود حق كلمة «ذكر»
حلو
بعدين اجمع عليها الباركود حق كلمة «أنثى»
بيطلع «ملك»؟
بيطلع باركود حق «ملكة»
«ملكة»
فهمت فكرة؟
ممتع
فهذه أول مشكلة على الأقل انحلت
أنه قدرنا نحوّل هذه الرموز وهذه...
بس هل اشتغلوا عليها؟
يعني أبغى أتخيل أنهم يروحون يسوونها بالإنقليزي
فهل اشتغلوا عليها أنهم يسوونها بالعربي؟
وللا هي الآلة صارت تفكّر وتشوف اللغات الثانية
وتبدأ تسوي الباركود
وتبدأ تحط العمليات الحسابية لحالها؟
ما تفرق حتى لو لغة برمجة
حتى «شات جي بي تي» وأخواتها
تعطيه أنت بس كمية نصوص
يعني ما فيه ملك، ملكة
كلمة مختلفة، يختلف تمامًا، فهمت علي؟
أن التراكيب اللغوية بين اللغات لحالها؛ تختلف
فمين اللي يفكر؟
هل الآلة صارت تفكر لحالها؟
أنت أعطيت الآلة هدف
وهي اكتشفت الطريق من نفسها
«شات جي بي تي» أنت تقول له
شوف أبغاك تتنبّأ بالكلمة هذه
إذا كانت هذه الكلمات هي اللي سبقتها
ممتاز
على قولة «جيفري هينتون» هذا واحد من الأعلام في المجال
قال: أنت فكر فيها، إذا فيه برنامج مرة جيد في التنبؤ بالنصوص
معناته ما قدر يسويه إلا لأنه فاهم النص
لأن هذه الطريقة أنك تقدر تتنبّأ
مثل لما بتعلّم ولدك
خلاص من بتختبره
تشيل عنه الجوال وتشيل عنه الوصول للإنترنت
وتوديه مدرسة ما هي متساهلة
تجبره خلاص؛ ما لك طريقة أنك تجيب درجات
إلا أننا فعلًا تتعلم
فـ «شات جي بي تي» أعطوه هذه المهمة
قالوا: أنت عندك الكلمات هذه؛ يلا تنبّأ بهذه
فما قدر إلا أنه يفهم
فوصل لطريقة أنه قدر يفهم
حتى تعطيه أي لغة الحين
ومن الطرافة في الموضوع هذا
أذكر قبل سنة، طلع خبر هذا اللي في قوقل
قال: أنه الآلة أصبحت واعية أو شيء
اللي استقال على شانها
أيوة، اللي استقال على شانها
فشوف، قبل سنة الكلام هذا
وأنا كنت أقولها كأني أنكّت على الموضوع
قلت: متى ما صارت الآلة تفهم جملة
«قم نقعد، تعبنا واحنا قاعدين نمشي»
ديك الساعة أقول أنها واعية
شفت التعقيدات في اللغة هذه والسياق المحلي وذا
أنا على بالي عطيتها جو اللي إن شاء الله بعد خمس سنوات
عطيتها «شات جي بي تي» وفهمها
واو!
وقلت له ترجمها بالإنقليزي؛ وترجمها
تخيل الجملة هذه
مستوعب؟
فهذا تعقيد ثاني في اللغة
اللغة بعد ترى...
من تعقيدات اللغة أنها ماهي مجرد مجموعة كلمات
لو مثلًا بنترجم لغة للغة
إيه بس خلاص، كل كلمة يقابلها كلمة
ويمكن بس اختلاف في الترتيب شوي
ومكتوبة بطريقة مختلفة
لا، فيه أفكار في لغة؛ ماهي موجودة في لغة ثانية
يعني مثلًا: فيه بعض اللغات تقدر تتكلم بدون سياق زمني
مثلًا بالإنقليزي لازم تحدد هل أنت ماضي وللا مضارع وللا مستقبل
في اللغة الصينية لا، تقدر تكون مبهم شوي
في بعض اللغات ما فيها كلمات اليمين ويسار وقدام ووراء
يتكلمون دائمًا شمال جنوب شرق غرب
مثلًا يقولك: هذه يدي الشمال، وهذه يدي الجنوب
ولو يروح كذا، يقولك: هذه يدي الشرق وهذه يدي الغرب
صدق
ففيه أشياء في اللغة
أحيانًا ما هي موجودة في لغات أخرى
هذا أول تحدي
أول شيء، فيه سياق وفيه معاني وفيه...
وثالث شيء اللي هو الترابط
المشكلة اللغة مو مثل الصورة
تعطيه صورة محددة
مقطع صوتي؛ في النهاية مقطع محدد
الجملة ممكن تكون عشرين كلمة
وآخر كلمة لها علاقة بالكلمة الأولى، وافهمه
صح
تخيل مثلًا، قاعد أسولف مع واحد
وأقول له: والله فاتك رحت ثمانية
وقابلت عبدالرحمن، واستقبلوني والله خير استقبال
وجاب لي «تركي» الله يعطيه العافية؛ موية
وسوينا الحلقة واستمتعنا
وبعدين وأنا طالع قلت مثلًا: تشرب من ماء الكوثر إن شاء الله
أنا قلت لمين؟
من اللي جاب لي موية؟
«تركي» لأنه جاب لي موية
مثال صعب شوية
في المثال هذا، أنا قلت: تشرب من ماء الكوثر، لأنه...
لأنه أعطاك الموية
لأن هو اللي أعطاني الموية
فلاحظ كلمة مرتبطة بأول الجملة
حتى يمكن أنها ما كانت واضحة لكم
فهذا الترابط؛ صعب شوي
فأول شيء سووه، قالوا
خلنا يصير فيه تغذية عكسية
يعني هذا الشبكة العصبية بدل ما أعطيها هذا الباركود
أعطيه الباركود
والمُخرج أعطيه كمُدخل للباركود الثاني
اللي هي الكلمة اللي بعدها
بحيث على الأقل يصير فيه سياق
أيش الكلمة اللي جت قبلي
اكتشفوا أن هذا ما نجح على مدى جمل طويلة
فيها صعوبات في التمرين وكذا
جاء بعدين فيه نموذج ثاني سموه
«الذاكرة الطويلة قصيرة المدى»
قال: لا، نسوي شيء بحيث أنه يحدد
أيش الأشياء اللي يتذكرها
وأيش الأشياء اللي ينساها بسرعة
وبرضه عطت قفزة شوي، بس ما حلّت المسألة
اللي حل المسألة يبدو الحين هو هذا
نموذج «المحوّلات» اللي طلع من قوقل 2017
اللي ركّز على فكرة التركيز
قال: لا، في الجملة فيه كلمات
أزيد عليها التركيز وأقلل عليها التركيز
هذا أول خلنا نقول إسهام
بس أكبر إسهام فيه صراحة اللي أشوفه
أنه صار قابل أنك تجزئ المسألة وتوزعها على 1000 كمبيوتر
أول النماذج هذه صعبة لأنها تسلسلية، ما تقدر توزعها
يعني ما أقدر مثلًا ...
خل نقول أطبخ كيكة وأقسمها قسمين كل وحدة في الفرن
واختصر الوقت
وبعدين نجمعهم
إيه، خلاص الكيكة تاخذ ساعة في الفرن؛ بتاخذ ساعة في الفرن
قسمتها نصين؛ بتاخذ ساعة ساعة
المحوّل؛ لا، سمح أنك تمرّن بالتوازي، وعلى بيانات هائلة
فصار سرعة التجربة أعلى بكثير
فهذا يمكن تطور الحل من ناحية لغوية
فيه شيء ثاني بعد هنا في موضوع اللغة
أن اللغة شوي مرتبطة بالتفكير
مثل لما تلقى واحد وهو يكلمك
صعب أنك تفكر بشيء ثاني
تراك تستعير جهازك اللغوي شوي
مثل لما بتتذكر أغنية؛ تقصّر المسجّل، تبغى...
لأنك قاعد تستعير جهازك
حتى لو ضيّعت الطريق أصلًا...
إيه، بالضبط
لو بتتذكر شيء؛ تلقاك تغمض وللا تناظر فوق
لأنك قاعد تستعير جهازك البصري
فنفس الكلام أنت لما تفكر
فيه جزء من مخك قاعد يتكلم
وقاعد تسمع نفسك
وقد سووها، يعني تقعد تراقب نشاط المخ
أثناء ما يفكر الوحد أو أثناء ما يتكلم
فيه مناطق متشابهة
ما أقولك كل التفكير لغوي
بس جزء كبير أو الجزء اللي ميزنا عن باقي الحيوانات
أنه عندنا اللغة هذه؛ اللي أعطتنا قدرة أن نفكر بأِشياء
والدليل شوف يا معلم «شات جي بي تي» اللغة
صار فاهم في البرمجة والشعر والفيزياء والكيمياء
ما دربوه، وقال: نبغاك تصير مبرمج
وللا نبغاك تصير شاعر
قال: بس تنبّأ بالكلمة اللي بعدها
اضطر أنه يفهم، ويوم فهم اللغة
صار يسوي أي مهمة لغوية
يعني كل الأشياء اللي يسويها «شات جي بي تي» الحين
أول كان في الذكاء الاصطناعي عندنا
كل وحدة رسالة دكتوراة
التلخيص تلقى فيه واحد حياته شغّال
على كيف أنه تعطي نص ويلخصه
الترجمة نفس الكلام
محاولة تقييم التعليقات، مثلًا تتنبّأ بالتعليقات
البرمجة، كيف أني مثلًا أخلي الآلة تبرمج؛ هذا حياة ثانية
صحيح
هذا أنت ما برمجته على شيء محدد
أنت برمجته على مهمة واحدة
وقدر منها يوصل للعموم
حتى في الإنسان، لو تعلمت لغة ثانية؛ تصير أذكى بشكل عام
لو تعلمت حتى موسيقى، تسميها نوع ثاني من اللغة
الآن بس عشان أعرف
«أوبن إيه آي» يوم سوّت «شات جي بي تي»
الحين هم علموه على فكرة واحدة في اللغات؟
أو في لغة واحدة، وهو بدأ يتعلم اللغات الثانية؟
وللا لأن اللغات كلها فكرتها وحدة
فكان منهجية واحدة في...
لا، أعطوه كل اللغات...
أنا قد سويتها
لأن أيش اللي صار؟
لأنك حتى في العربي مو بس أن السياق يفهمه
ويعرف إذا أردت أن حطيته مثلًا مذكر
يعني يفهم في سياق الجملة
يفهم حتى باللهجات، بكل اللهجات المحلية
في السعودية مثلًا لحاله
وللا حتى اللهجات على كل العالم العربي
صحيح إيه
المسألة معقدة
شوف أخذت كم قوقل
إلى أن فعّلت اللغة العربية في البحث
وأنها بدأت تفهمه
أخذت مدري كم؟ عشر سنين
هذا في نفس الوقت صار
قصدك «بارد»
لا لا، لا سيبك من «بارد»
يعني قوقل قبل، قبل وجود الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنا أتكلم على أن فهم اللغات في البحث ما كان سهل
فكان أول شيء الإنقليزي، تتذكر؟
إيه، بس أول قوقل في البحث ما كانت...
ذكية؟
تبحث بشكل الكلمة
يعني لما تكتب مثلًا كمبيوتر
يبحث لك عن الكلام هذا
ما يبحث لك عن كمبيوتر وجهاز ولابتوب بالمعنى
بس كان فيها التصنيف، وكان فيها...
لا، بالعكس أصلًا أيش اللي خلّى قوقل قوقل؟
أيش اللي خلاه؟
اللي هي «بيج رانك»
«بيج رانك» ماهي معتمدة...
أول كانت المدرسة القديمة في البحث
على الكلمات، وصار على الروابط
على الكلمات يعني مثلًا لو تبحث عن «إبراهيم مسلّم»
يبحث لك في المواقع
ويشوف أيش أكثر موقع متكرر فيه «إبراهيم مسلّم»
ويرتب لك إياها، هذا أكثر موقع تكرر فيه اسم «إبراهيم مسلّم»
«بيج رانك» لا، قال: أنا بشوف الروابط
لما تقول «إبراهيم مسلّم» الروابط اللي تشير إلى وين؟
فاخترعوا خوارزمية «بيج رانك»
ممكن الرابط، أول صفحة يمكن صفحتي الشخصية
اللي مو مكتوب فيها «إبراهيم مسلّم» إلا مرة واحدة
فأصلًا يعني قوقل...
فما كان لها علاقة باللغة قصدك
مو ما كان لها علاقة بالنصوص
لا، لها علاقة بنصوص
بس الشاهد هنا أذهلني أن «أوبن إيه آي»
يوم أعلنت عن «شات جي بي تي 4» وللا «شات جي بي تي 3»
يوم دخلت اللغة؛ أنه ما تطلب
يعني أصبح تطور اللغة العربية يوازي الإنقليزية في نفس المنحنى
مع أنه تدري كم نسبة اللغة العربية من البيانات
التي تدربوا عليها «أوبن إيه آي»
كم تتوقع؟
ما أدري
أقل من 0.5% وشوف تعلّم
كل هذا الانبهار من اللغة العربية
ترى أقول له اعرب ويعرب، تخيل!
وهذه المعلومات حصّل عليها من الإنترنت بس؟
كيف؟
بس اللي في الإنترنت هذه المعلومات
شوف «أوبن إيه آي» طبعًا...
يا أخي «أوبن إيه آي» أنا أسميهم مثل الحرامي اللي اسمه شريف
اللي أي شيء إلا مفتوح
«أوبن إيه آي» يسهمون في موضوع الوصول المفتوح
ما أدري كيف سووها بالضبط
بس النسبة هذه أعلنوا عنه نسبة 0.05% أو 0.04%
ناسي الرقم، رقم قليل أقل من 0.5%
ومع ذلك شوف كل الانبهار هذا
لأنه مثل ما قلت لك؛ تعلّم لغة يفيدك في لغة ثانية
يعني مو بمعناته لو شلت كل اللغات الثانية
وتمرنت على بس هذه الكمية
بتجيك نفس النتيجة اللي جاتك من «شات جي بي تي 4»
لا «شات جي بي تي 4» تعلّم من هذه، واللغات الثانية...
وقالوها قد مرة في مؤتمر أو شيء
قالوا: يوم زاد لغات؛ تحسّنت لغات ثانية
أيش يتطلب حتى تتفوق الآلة على الإنسان؟
والله «شات جي بي تي 4» أذكى من ناس كثير أعرفهم صراحة
حتى أكون صادق
ما أقولك أذكى من كل البشر
بس هذه مثل ما قلت لك، سؤال اللي فكروا فيه من زمان
و«تورينق» قال: إذا ما قدرت تفرّق فما فيه فرق
فاختبار «تورينق» إذا ما قدرت تميّز أو إذا...
مثل «شات جي بي تي 4» كيف اختبروه؟
كيف؟
اختبروه حتى بعد على...
عدّى اختبار «البار» حق المحاماة في أمريكا
صحيح
عدل اختبارات المعايير
وجاب أفضل من الإنسان
فطرق كثيرة نقدر نختبره فيها
هل هو أفضل من الإنسان وللا لا؟
تقدر تأخذها جانب جانب
مثل في «الآي كيو»
لما الناس تجد...
يا كثرهم اللي وقعوا على عريضة
إيه
وللا خافوا
فيه حقت «ديب ماينت» هو اللي...
الظاهر في قوقل، هو اللي استقال؟
إيه «جيفري هينتون» اللي في قوقل
تمام، فيا كثر الناس اللي يتوقعون أن الآلة بتدمر البشرية
صحيح
وحتى منهم الناس اللي لهم علاقة بالذكاء الاصطناعي
«إيلون ماسك» وللا «سام ألتمن» وللا غيره
أيش خايفين منه؟
خلني أبغى أعرف
إذا أنا الآن ما أقدر أتخيل بصدق وين رايحين؟
أيش اللي يشوفونه مثلًا بعد مدري كم سنة، وخايفين منه
أيش هو هذا؟
يعني كيف بتدمر الإنسان؟
شوف مو بلازم تعرف كيف بيتدمر الإنسان
عشان أقدر أتنبّأ أنه بيتدمر الإنسان
بعطيك مثال
يدمر مو حتى الإنسان؛ تتدمر البشرية
تنتهي البشرية
نرجع لمثال السيارة
لما أقولك أنا أتوقع فيه احتمال أنه يصير حادث
مو معناته أنا توقعي أنه بيصير حادث
بس في سياق الذكاء الاصطناعي
لما أقول لك أن فيه شيء أذكى منك بكثير
وقلنا الحين: الذكاء هو الوصول إلى الأهداف
ممتاز
فإذا صار فيه تعارض في الأهداف؛ البقاء للأذكى
مثلًا، الشطرنج، بستهلكه اليوم، معليش
تخيل جيتك يا عبدالرحمن وقلت: شوف...
بس ترى فيه ناس عندهم إشكال مع الشطرنج
لأنك مكثّر فيه
كيف؟ من أي ناحية؟
لأنه إحصائي بحت
هو ترى لما تستخدم مثال
عشان تعزل كل المتغيرات وتركز على فكرة معينة
وتشرح فيها فكرة معينة
ماهي بالتشبيه عادي يساوي، عرفت؟
تخيل جيت قلت لك: أنا لقيت لي خطة بالشطرنج
وبتحدى فيها بطل العالم في الشطرنج
وبراهن على بيتي وفلوسي
وخلاص متأكد منها
بتقول لي: يا إبراهيم، أهدى من كذا، ترى يمكن يفوز عليك
أجي أقول لك: طيب ورني كيف بيفوز علي؟
تقول: يا أخي ما أدري، لو أني أدري كان صرت بطل العالم
أقول لك: يلا هذه الخطة، وفكرت فيها
جربت مع الشباب في الاستراحة، وكلهم مشت عليهم
تقول: أنت بتباري بطل العالم في الشطرنج
فيه فرق كبير في الذكاء يعني
وبعدين تجي مثلًا تقول: يلا يمكن بيلعب كذا
وأجي أنا أرد عليك
وبعدين تقول: خلاص، ما دام أنا لعبت هذه، فهو ما راح يلعب
نفس الكلام لما يصير عندك شيء بالتعريف أذكى منك بكثير
وصار فيه تعارض في الأهداف
أقدر أتنبّأ أنه بيفوز، من بدون ما أتنبّأ كيف بيسوي
تخيل جيت وسوينا المباراة هذه
جيت ولعبت معك «ماقنوس كارلسن»
وأنت قاعد تشوف المباراة
أنت يمكن لأن مستواك قريب مني
بتقدر تقول: والله شكله إبراهيم بيلعب اللعبة دي
شكله بيلعب ذي
بس ما تقدر تتنبّأ أيش بيسوي معك «ماقنوس كارسلن» بطل العالم
صح؟
صح
بتقدر تقول أيش... وللا صرت أنت بطل العالم
بس سهل مرة تتنبأ أنه بيفوز عليك
نفس الفكرة منطقية
إذا قلت لك... نبسطها مرة
في كيانين، هذا أذكى من هذا بكثير
حلو
بس هذا هدفه يتعارض مع هذا
أنت تبغى تصير في هذه الحالة؟
لا
فأنت الحين يا أنك تحافظ على أنك تكون أذكى منه
وللا تتأكد أن أهدافكم متوائمة
هذه مشكلة الموائمة في الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنه كيف أتأكد لما أبني ذكاء اصطناعي خارق أذكى مني
تكون أهدافنا مشتركة
أنت ما عندك مشكلة ترى في الذكاء
مشكلتك مو في الذكاء؛ مشكلتك بالأهداف
يعني أنت الحين...
الرسول عليه الصلاة والسلام قال
«اللهم أعز الإسلام بأحد العمرين»
الشخص القوي الذكي؛ أنت تبغاه في فريقك
بالعكس ما عندك مشكلة
المشكلة إذا صار ضدك
نرجع لمثال الذكاء والأهداف
تخيل الحين أنا أجيب ذكاء اصطناعي خارق
وقلت له الحين بنعطيه هدف
بعطيه هدف مرة بسيط وواضح
والمفروض ما يصير عليه خلاف
وأقول له مثلًا: قلل عدد الوفيات البشرية
عندك مانع أنه يكتبها؟
أبد
أضغط إدخال؟
اضغط إدخال
تكتشف أنه بيقوم وبيحاول يذبح كل البشر
ليش؟
ليه؟ لأن هو بيحسبها، بيقول: الحين فيه 8 مليارات
بس الناس بيموتون بيموتون
بقعد أحافظ عليهم، بعد فترة معينة
بعد 100 سنة أو 200 سنة أو 300 سنة
الـ 8 مليار كلهم بيموتون
وقد جابوا ناس جدد
في عام 2317 بيصير عدد الوفيات 8 مليار وواحد
أقل من 8 مليار وواحد
شوف أنا بالغت في المثال عشان أوضح فكرة
أنك أحيانًا قد يبدو لك هدف مره واضح
بعدين تكتشف أنه...
بعدين يلا الحين في صراع مع هذه الآلة
اللي تبغى تذبح كل البشر وهي أذكى منك
هي كيف تقدر؟
يعني لنفرض أنك ضغطت إدخال، كيف بتقتلني؟
تروح أيش تسوّي؟
تطعني يا أخي
ترى مو بلازم تذبحك ثاني يوم
حلو، أيش بتسوّي؟ خلني أفهمك وأتخيل معك
مثل ما قلت لك
ماهو مطالب مني حتى أني أعطيك سيناريو
كأنك تقول كيف بيفوز علي بطل العالم
أنا قاعد أقول لك...
لا، بس أنا أنا بقولك، معليش
الفرق أيش؟ أني أقدر أتخيل مسرح اللعبة
وأقدر أتخيل وشلون بيسوون
وأقدر أتخيل كيف بيفوز علي
أنه بيسوي حركات إلى أن يهزم الملك حقي
فعندي تصوّر كيف بيفوز علي، فهمت علي؟
إيه فاهم
بس الآلة لما تقول أنها هي تبغى تقتلك
أنا بمشي معك، لأنه منطقيًّا ممكن تروح تسوي مثل كذا
بس فعليًّا شلون بتروح تسوي؟
أيش بتسوي؟
يعني شلون بتوصل إلى عبدالرحمن
اللي متكّي هنا في الرياض وتقتله؟ هذا قصدي
أول شيء، أنت لازم تحط ببالك
أن طول نفس العالم مو مثل طول نفسك
مو لازم بيذبحك ثاني يوم
ترى ممكن يصبر خمسين أو ستين سنة
حلو
إذا كان هذا هدفه؛ عادي يتمسكن حتى يتمكن
يجي يشوف «شات جي بي تي»
الحين والله يا أخي بديت أستحي منه
كونت علاقة عاطفية معه
شوية أقول له عرفت اللي...
أبو أيش يا «شات جي بي تي»؟
شفنا هذاك اللي أيش اسمه؟ أيش «بينق»؟
اللي قاعد يحاول يقنع واحد يطلق زوجته
مدري يترك زوجته
في واحد انتحر بسبة الذكاء الاصطناعي التوليدي
واو!
إيه انتحر، اقنعه أنه ينتحر
فغرس الأفكار هذه على مدى طويل
وبعدين يتفشى كذا في كل الأجهزة
لما تصير حياتنا معتمدة على الذكاء الاصطناعي
صعب أنك تقول: والله خلاص بفصل الفيش
وممكن ببساطة مثلًا ...
حتى فيه إشاعة أو احتمال أنه كورونا كانت عن طريق «تسريب معملي»
يعني طلعت...
تسربت من المعمل؟
أيوة تسربت من المعمل
هل ممكن يسوي شيء بيولوجي؟
هل ممكن...
أمر بسيط، مفاعل نووي يسوي لك
«تشرنوبل» آخر، عشرة في العالم
أنت تخيل لك مليون سيناريو
بس كل سيناريو بتجي تقول لي: طيب كذا طيب كذا؟
أنت لا تحط نفسك في سيناريو
في شيء أذكى منك بكثير
وفيه أهدافه أو تعارض الهداف
وفيه بعد فكرة ثانية مفروض أتكلم عنها
اللي هي توّي أقولك الأهداف الوسيطة
أنا حتى لو ما أعرف هدفك النهائي
ممكن أتنبّأ بأشياء تسويها، أهداف وسيطة
مثال
تخيل يا عبدالرحمن، أنت عندك أهداف في الحياة
وأنا عندي أهداف في الحياة
«تركي» عنده أهداف في الحياة
أنت كان هدفك تبغى تسوي إمبراطورية إعلامية
تغيّر شكل الإعلام العربي والعالمي وإلى آخره
«تركي» يمكن يبغى يصير كاتب، روائي
واحد ثاني عندك يمكن يبغى يصير مصمم رسومات
أنت تبغى يخدمك استديو، يخدمك معدات، موظفين
هذا يخدمه مثلًا مكتبة
هذا يخدمه مثلًا جهاز «ماك بوك»
كل هذه يساعده حتى يوصل الهدف النهائي
بس كلكم لو أجيكم وأقول لكم
تبغون مليون ريال؟ ما أحد بيقول لا
لأن الفلوس هدف يسمونه وسيط عام
ما يحتاج أعرف هدفك؛ عشان أعرف أنك تحتاجه
تحتاجه
والإحصائيين أيش يسوون؟
ما يحاول يتنبّأ بهدف كل شخص
قال: أفترض أن كل هدفه فلوس
وخل ننمدج
ويوصلون إلى نتائج دقيقة
فهذا أول شيء
أنت مجرد ما يصير عندك هدف؛ ما يحتاج أعرفه
أنت بتبحث عن الموارد
ثاني شيء من صالحك البقاء
لأن مو من صالح الهدف؛ أنك تموت
صح وللا لا؟
ثالثًا من صالحك أنك تطور نفسك
ليش الإنسان يتعلم ويهتم بصحته؟
لأن تطوير الذات يساعدك للوصول إلى هدفك
رابعًا -لا إله إلا الله- التحكّم
ليش بعض الناس يحب أنه يكون...
بعض الناس يا أخي يطلع من وظيفته ويسوي إعادة تشغيل
يقول: عشان أبغى أصير أنا المتحكم
لما تصير متحكم بمناخكم ومحيطك
هذا هدف وسيط عام
أنا مجرد ما يكون أي شيء له هدف
أقدر أتنبّأ أن من صالح الهدف؛ أنه حتى ما يتغيّر
مثال: الحبّة اللي آكلها وتخليني أكره عيالي
مو من صالح الهدف أنه يتغيّر
مو من صالح الهدف أنه يموت
من صالح الهدف أنه يطوّر من نفسه
من صالح الهدف أنه يحصل على أمواله
من صالح الهدف أنه يتحكم بمناخه
فأنت لا تضغط زر
وهذا الشيء أذكى منك بكثير
بيسوي هذه الأمور على نار هادية
حبة حبة؛ بيحصل أموال
حبة حبة؛ بيتحكم
حبة حبة؛ بيطور نفسه
إلى أن توصل مرحلة يدري إنك ما تقدر...
وطبعًا مو من صالحك أنك تطفيه
ليه مو من صالحي؟
مو من صالحه هو
لو جاء بيقولك: طيب عادي بفصل الفيش
على أساس ما راح تخطر على بال الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق
اللعبة أيش هو؟ فيش وأحوّل
مثل ما قلت لك بينتشر في كل مكان
هل تقدر تفصل الإنترنت؟
يعني...
بفيش واحد كذا، عرفت؟
يعني نظريًّا تقدر، فعليًّا ما تقدر
نظريًّا فيه أنه تقدر تفصل الإنترنت صح؟
فيه لازم بس هو ...
بس أنها بتخرب الحياة شوي
طيب، تخيل قد انتشر فايروس وقضينا
يلا افصله؛ بتموت
هذا بنقعد ندخل فيه أمثلة سيناريوهات
أنا أقولك
فيه واحد فيه كيانين: ذكاء واحد أكثر من الثاني
وفيه أهداف متعارضة
إذا كان الفرق كبير؛ البقاء للأذكى
فهذا اللي مخوف الناس
ما شفت ترى تصنيف الذكاء الاصطناعي
وخطره الوجودي من زمان
«آلن تورينق» اللي هو كما قلت لك «أينشتاين» حقنا
كان متنبّأ بالشيء هذا
كان متخوف من خطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
بسبب خطر وجودي
جامعة «أكسفورد» فيه مركز اسمه «معهد مستقبل البشرية»
وفيه مركز في «كامبريدج» اسمه
مركز «التهديدات الوجودية»
هذه مراكز مهتمة بالمخاطر الوجودية
النيازك، الأوبئة، الاحتباس الحراري
انتشار الأسلحة النووية، الذكاء الاصطناعي
هو في هذا القالب من زمان
يتعاملون معه على أنه خطر وجودي
يعني تروح المراكز هذه يقولك
هذا فلان شغّال في الأوبئة، وهذا شغال في الاحتباس الحراري
وهذا شغال في الذكاء الاصطناعي
وكما قلت لك مو بشيء جديد
توّنا نستوعب أن الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق
ممكن يسبب خطر وجودي
«آلن تورينق» اللي أسس مجال الحاسب والذكاء الاصطناعي
كان متنبئ بالشيء ذا
اللي مؤلف كتاب الذكاء الاصطناعي
هذا اللي أي واحد درس ذكاء اصطناعي في الجامعة
هذا الكتاب اللي احنا ذاكرناه وحلينا الواجبات واختبرنا فيه
مع أن الذكاء الاصطناعي بيسبب خطر وجودي
خطر وجودي على البشرية؟
خطر وجودي على البشرية
مو معناته أنه يتنبّأ بأن هو بيبيدنا
فيه فرق بين أنه يتنبّأ أنه بيبيدنا ومثل مثال السيارة
وممكن يكون خطر وجودي
إذا ما بنيناه بطريقة آمنة
فإذا كان عندك ذكاء اصطناعي خارق
صار فيه تعارض في الأهداف
طيب معليش، عرّف الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق
الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق اللي يتفوق على كل البشرية
في كل شيء؟ وللا في مجال محدد؟
لا لا، في كل شيء عام
في كل شيء عام
يعني أذكى من البشر مجتمعين
في عموميات الحياة؟
مثل الفرق بينها وبين النملة، باختصار
ومو بعيد؟
يا رجال الفرق بين «شات جي بي تي 4» و«شات جي بي تي 3»
قفزة
أيش بيطلع «شات جي بي تي 8» وللا؟
«شات جي بي تي 5»
«شات جي بي تي 5» بيدخلك الحين في «النماذج المتعددة»
ويدخل في الصور، ويدخل في الأصوات
فهمت الفكرة؟ التركيبة هذه كلها منطقيًّا
أنت ما تبغى تكون في هذا الموضع
ليش تحط نفسك في موضع
شيء أنت بالنسبة له نملة
وأهدافكم متعارضة
يمكن مو بس يبغى يبيدك عشان بس يبغى يبيدك
ماهو الأهداف أهدافي؟
هذه النقطة
يعني هل هو يقدر يفكر لحاله بدوني؟
أنا اللي في الأخير بضغط إدخال
بدون ما أضغط إدخال
هو مو بجالس يسوي شيء
فهمت علي؟
هذا هو السؤال...
يعني أهدافنا متطابقة
هذا سؤال المليون دولار
الحين الناس أيش قاعدين يبحثون؟
أيش يبحثون؟
هذا مجال السؤال المفتوح
اللي كيف أبني ذكاء اصطناعي أضمن إنه أهدافنا متوائمة
تعطيه هدف صريح بيلقى ثغرات
وإذا لغى ثغرة أنت ما انتبهت لها؛ ما في عودة
مثل السؤال اللي أعطيتك إياه قبل شوي
وقلت اضغط إدخال
ويلا عاد قابل ذكاء اصطناعي خارق
ما يبغاك تطفيه، ويبغى يحصل على موارد
يبغى يتحكم ويبغى ويبغى
فكرة أنك تعطيه هدف واضح ومحدد
مثل لما تقول لولدك يلا روح غرفتك
بعدين تجي الساعة اثنا عشر؛ تلقاه ما بعد نام
يقول: ما قلت لي نم
يبدأ، يلقى ثغرات
وهذه يسمونه «اختراق الكلمات»
هو مصطلح، اللي ممكن يلقى ثغرة
تقنيًّا سوّى الشيء اللي أنت تبغاه
مثل المثال اللي قلته، اللي ذبح من الـ 8 مليار
قلل عدد الوفيات البشرية
بس أنه مو بالشيء اللي أنت تبغاه فعلًا
فهو في النهاية بيبحث عن زيادة المكافأة اللي في مخه
هذه «نظام الكلمات»
عشان كذا يسمونها «اختراق الكلمات»
مثل عندنا في البشر «الدوبامين»
أنت ترى كل الأشياء اللي تسويها أحيانًا
عشان ترفع «الدوبامين»
لو تعلمت شيء جديد، لو قابلت أصدقائك
يرتفع «الدوبامين»
بس تدري لو أعطيتك وصول إلى «الدوبامين» حقك
وجربوه مع الحيوانات
مع فأر، أو ناسي أيش هو الحيوان
قعد يضغطه لما مات
إذا قدر الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق يوصل للاختراق هذا، أني...
أيش هو الهروين والمخدرات هذه؟
ترى يرفع «الدوبامين»
عشان كذا الإدمان لما الواحد يموت
بس شوف الفرق، أحس الحين لما جبت المثال مثلًا
سواءً حق النوم وللا حق الوفيات
أن طريقته في التنفيذ غبية
يعني لو واحد قلت له...
يعني نفس المثال، وراح سوى نفس الطريقة
بتقول: أنت غبي؟! ما فهمت أيش أقصد؟!
مو معناته أني لما أعطيتك السياق كامل؛ بتصير غبي
فهل الآلة بتبقى بهذا الغباء؟
يعني ما تفهم أيش أقصد أنا أقول يحافظ على بشرية
قصدي يحافظ عن البشرية يعني
ما قلت لك يقتلهم
فهل بيبقى غبي؟
أنت باني...
وللا أنا فكرتي للغباء خطأ؟
أنت باني استنتاجك على افتراض خاطئ
حلو
اللي هو: أن فيه علاقة بين الذكاء والأهداف
اللي قلت لك إياها قبل
أنه مثبتة ترى، يعني هذه نظرية منشورة في بحث علمي محكّم
وتقدر تقول مثبتة
ماهي نظرية رياضية؛ نظرية فلسفية
بس أنها متكاملة الأركان
أنك ما تقدر تربط التصرفات
وتقدر تستنتج منها الأهداف
ولا الأهداف... التصرفات
وهذا هي المسألة اللي قاعدين نحاول نحلها
فترى التوجه الحين مو أنك تعطيه هدف
التوجه الحين أنك تقوله: حاول تستنتج هدف البشر
يعني أنت هدفك حاول تفهم هدف الإنسان
وهذا طرح اللي هو «ستيوارت راسل»
مؤلف كتاب منهج الذكاء الاصطناعي في الجامعات
وحط ثلاث مبادئ
وفي مجال ترى اسمه «الذكاء الاصطناعي مثبت الفائدة»
كيف أني أبني ذكاء اصطناعي أقدر أثبت أننا متوأمين
حلو
وحط ثلاث مبادئ
قال: أول وحدة، أن الذكاء الاصطناعي ما له هدف محدد
هدفه يحاول يستنتج هدف البشر من تصرفاتهم
يكون دائمًا عنده نسبة شك
يعني مثلًا أنت الآن قاعد تشرب قهوة
لو أنا روبوت وأول مرة أشوفك، بقول:
ما أدري، يمكن عبدالرحمن يحب القهوة
بكرة شاهي، بعده عصير
بس لو كل يوم طلبت قهوة، طلبت قهوة
كلما زاد نسبة أنه شكله عبدالرحمن راعي قهوة
بس ما تصل صفر
يعني لازم يبقى معامل شك
وأنا وظيفتي أني أحاول أستنتج الأهداف من التصرفات
اللي هو أنا أسميه في الأساس نظام المدام
اللي ما تقولك أيش تبغى؟
أنت شوفت وعرفت؛ حاول تستنتج من التصرفات
وخلك دايم في شك، فهمت قصدي؟
اللي بتعطيك إياها صريحة وأيش تبغى؟
مستحيل
انسى الموضوع. أنت لو يهمك كان عرفت
إيه كل التعب، وفي الأخير طلعوا جابوها من زمان
الشاهد أنه هذا فكرة -لا إله إلا الله- نسيت اسمه توني قايله
راسل؟
إيه «ستيوارت راسل»
وتقدر تربطها بمجال في الرياضيات اسمه «نظرية الألعاب»
الترجمة الحرفية ما توصل المعنى
يمكن خلنا نقول هي نظرية استراتيجيات
ما أدري إذا كنت شفت فيلم «تفكير جميل»
قصة عالم هذا «جون ناش»
اللي هو من المسهمين في مجال «نظرية الألعاب»
ومشرفه، طرح معضلة من معضلات السجناء
بشرحه عشان تفهم فكرة «ستيوارت»
اللي هي: أفرض أني وياك يا عبدالرحمن
سوينا جريمة ومسكونا الشرطة
وحطوا كل واحد في غرفة
وقالوا لنا: احنا ما عندنا أدلة كافية تدينكم على الجريمة
بس فيه أدلة كافية على أشياء ثانية
فممكن إذا كلكم سكتوا؛ بتاخدون سنة كل واحد
إذا كلكم اعترفتوا؛ بتاخدون خمسة سنين
بس إذا واحد اعترف والثاني سكت
اللي اعترف؛ بيروح براءة
واللي سكت؛ ياخذ عشر سنين
فالمفروض أيش؟
أفضل استراتيجية هنا بالنسبة للي أنا ولك
نسكت
نسكت صح، كل واحد ياخذ سنة
بس أيش يضمن لي أنك بتسكت؟
بالضبط
يعني أنا الحين بقعد في غرفة لحالي
بقول: دقيقة لو عبدالرحمن أعترف
وأنا سكتت
إيه، وأنا سكتت؛ فهو بيروح براءة وأنا باخذ عشر سنين
لا، بعترف
ولو عبدالرحمن سكت
أحسن لي أعترف وأروح براءة
خلّه يقعد
فوصلنا لنقطة اللي كلنا خمس سنين
مع أن الأفضل لنا كلنا سنة
النقطة هذه اللي يسمونها نقطة «توازن ناش»
اللي مسمّى على الرجل هذا اللي في الفيلم
فنظرية الألعاب هذه
اللي أنت كيف تقدر تستنتج وين نقطة التوازن؟
فهو طرحها كأنها مثل لعبة بين الطرفين: الإنسان والآلة
هدف الآلة أنها تحاول تستنتج أهداف البشر
يعني «توازن ناش» في هذه الحالة
أن الآلة بتحاول تفهم أيش تبغى
وأنت بتحاول تفهمها أيش تبغى
هنا بتكون نقطة توازن
فبدل ما تعطيه هدف صريح 100%
أنت تعطيه هدف غير مباشر
وتقدر تتنبّأ وين نقطة التوازن بتكون
فهذه فكرة «ستيوارت راسل»
فيه أفكار في كيف نبنيه بطريقة آمنة
بس أبداً ماهي باللي...
أكيد ما راح...
على الأفلام، شفت «مهمة مستحيلة» الأخير؟
لا والله ما شفته، ليه؟
أبغاك تشوفه
لأنه باني فكرته على ماذا لو كان
اللي يتحكم في البشر هو آلة؟
فأصبحت آلة كذا، تقدر تتحكم في البشر
يبغى لك تشوفه
وعلى طاري الأفلام برضه
تعرف رواية «فرانكشتاين»؟
«فرانكشتاين» هذا الطبيب اللي قدر يخلق إنسان آلي
جاب أجزاء من جثث
يد من جثة، ومخ من جثة
وبعدين صعقها صعقة كهربائية
من الكهرباء اللي هي آخر التقنية
فبعد فترة الوحش هذا
بدأ يتمرد على دكتور «فرانكشتاين»
قال له: حتى من كذا، أنا اللي خالقك
أيش قال له في الرواية؟
قال: أنت خالقي، لكني أنا سيدك. فاسمع وأطِع
فمو معناته أنك أنت بنيت الشيء
معناته أنك عندك قدرة تحكّم عليه
أي واحد عنده عيال بيعرف
والله صدق
يعني عيالك دمك ولحمك؛ تمردوا
طيب، فأنت تحتاج آليات للسيطرة على أولادك
صحيح
هل ممكن؟
من الأشياء اللي أنت تطالب فيها
وفيه كثير يطالبون فيها
أن تدخل الحكومات في ضبط
وتحكم وحوكمة الذكاء الاصطناعي
والحكومات قدرت أنها تسويها مع أشياء ثانية
نعتقد أنها مضرة
مثلًا عندنا القنابل النووية
ففيها هذا الحوكمة بشكل أو بآخر
بس في الذكاء الاصطناعي كيف ممكن يصير هذا؟
يعني أيش الطلبات
وأيش الأشياء اللي بتخلي مستقبل البشرية آمن؟
وحدة منها أنك تراقب استهلاك الحوسبة والبيانات
كيف؟
بيبان لك
لو فيه منظمة دولية تراقب بناء نماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي
مين اللي قاعد يسحب بيانات من كل مكان؟
مين اللي قاعد يستهلك طاقة حوسبية معينة؟
في هذا واحد في «تيد توك»
واحد كذا «غريب الأطوار»
أماكن مزارع قوقل هذه ماهي معلنة
وقدر يستنتج من فواتير الكهرباء
وطاقة وما أدري أيش، وين
واحد عبقري
شوف مثل...
إذا واحد لحاله فالحكومة تقدر...
مثل على قولتك انتشار الاسلحة النووية
يعني تقدر تتنبّأ
فيه مصادر مواد الخام
هذه معينة من وين تجي، وتراقبها
فالبيانات هي «اليورانيوم» الجديد
اللي منها تقدر تعرف من اللي قاعد يبني وتراقبه
بعدين شوف لو تلاحظ الشركات الحين
قاعدة تقول للحكومات: أرجوكم حوكمونا
بس فيه ناس تقول
أن طلباتهم لأنهم يبغون يخلون الحكومات
تشوف شيء ما ينتبهوا له هم
فجالس يقول له: انتبه لهذا الشيء؛ وأنا جالس...
لأنه غير منطقي أنك تطالب بالحوكمة
إيه وعلى قولتهم قالوا الحوكمة...
فما أعرف يعني فيه...
إيه، هو غلط أنك تجيب الشركات تسألهم أيش نسوي؟
ومع ذلك قالوا حوكمونا
يعني على قولتهم: قل للحرامي يحلف؛ قال جاك الفرج
ما ينفع تسأل
يعني كأنك تقول للطالب: صحح ورقتك
وبرضه في نفس الوقت المشرعين ما يفهمون
خصوصًا في أمريكا
مو كلهم عندهم هذه المعرفة بالذكاء الاصطناعي
والتقنية اللي وين واصلة
بس تقدر تستعين بخبراء وتفصلها
كلهم حق الشركات في الأخير
إيه هذا مشكلة منافسة، يسحبونهم صح
بس أيش اللي يمكن؟
يعني أنت لما تقول مثلًا في الذكاء الاصطناعي
خلني أشوف كيف
إنه بيبان إذا الواحد يسوي وللا لا، مثل القنابل النووية
بس اللي يختلف بينها؛ إن هذه فعلًا تبان
ويتطلب جهود حكومات
لبناء مفاعل نووي واحد
بس الذكاء الاصطناعي؛ أنا وأنت هنا نقدر نسويه
لا!
ليه؟
تقدر تسوي مثل «شات جي بي تي»؟
إيه
ما تقدر
ليش لا؟
يبغى لك معالجات
طيب، فيه عندي نشتري
شوف الأسبوع اللي راح واللي قبله
كان في خبر في «فاينانشال تايمز»
أن السعودية بتشتري
من «إنفيديا»؟
إيه من «إنفيديا» 3000
وقالوا أنه...
أثارت مخاوف سوء الاستخدام
بيبدون يلعبون لعبة الأخلاقيات هذه
مثل ما لعبتها «أوبن إيه آي»
«أوبن إيه آي» في البدايات كان كل ما نقول لهم
اطلقوا نماذجكم
قالوا: لا، الأخلاقيات واحنا خايفين
بعدين في الأخير اعترفوا، قالوا: منافسة
آخر واحد قالوا: لسبب المنافسة الشديدة ما راح نعلن
الحين يقولك: لا والله بيلعبون
كرت سوء استخدام التقنية
ما أدري من فيه دولة ثانية بعد قد أساءت استخدام التقنية
مفهومة هذه
بس إذا جيت تبغى تشتريها
مثلًا حتى «إيلون ماسك» يوم راح واشتراه
ووقع العريضة؛ فالناس قاموا عليه
من «إنفيديا» برضه
بس أن تطور التقنية برضه في الأجهزة
يخلي أن الناس تقدر تسويها
ففيه هذا مثل «توني بوكس» وغيره
اللي جالس يشتغلون عليه
اللي نقدر نشتغل عليه أنا وأنت
نماذج مقصقصة ومهذبة ونظيفة ومحدودة
بس أني أبني نموذج اللي يشكل خطر
مثل «شات جي بي تي» قبل التعديل
أو قبل ما يهذبونه على قولتهم
يبغى لك تبني البيانات من الصفر
مشروع كبير هذا
بس نقدر نسويه
يتطلب فلوس شوي صح؟
لا لا
أيش يتطلب؟
يتطلب بيانات
يلا بتقدر تجمع بيانات؟ بتجيك...
إيه بجمعهم من الإنترنت
بيخلونك؟
يعني الحين صارت بيخلونها «آي بي آيز» وكذا
إيه لأنها مفتوحة
أنت بس ابحث في الإنترنت، صح؟
الحين قوقل مثلًا عندها «قوقل بوكس»
هذه تقدر تتمرن عليها على كيفك
100%
أنت لو بتبدأ تسحب؛ بيبدأ يبان
أيش ذا اللي قاعد يسحب من هنا ومن هنا
يقفل، بيقفلونه ماهي ...
مثل ما تقول أنت واضحة وسهلة وموجودة بالإنترنت
تحسب أنه قوقل ما يقدرون يعرفون أنك تسحب؟
يبان يبان
إلا يبان، والحين بدأت الشركات
«راديت» وتوتير؛ كلهم قفلوا
لأنه معاد أحد يقدر يسحب البيانات منهم. مفهوم
بس أنا قصدي مقارنة الذكاء الاصطناعي بالمفاعلات النووية
أن الذكاء الاصطناعي يمدي أي أحد يسويه
لا يتطلب هذا الشغل لإنتاج مفاعل نووي
أنا أقول لك الكلام هذا غير صحيح
والله؟
بقدرة «شات جي بي تي» من الصفر؟ ما تقدر
تحتاج يا رجل...
الحين تدريب نموذج «شات جي بي تي» لواحد
أخذ منه شهر ونصف
وكلّف «مايكروسوفت» مدري كم مليون دولار
عشان بس تدربه
ناهيك عن تجمع بيانات وتنظفها وو
أنا وأنت نقدر نحمّل نموذج مطبوخ وقاضي
اللي حطه على الميكروويف
بس أنه محدد أنت أيش تقدر عليه
أيش اللي يتطلب عشان نسويه أنا وأنت نموذج؟
يبغى لك تجمع بيانات
ولما تجمع بيانات، على طول بتطلع في الرادار
وبيجون يلعبون
تعال من أنت يا عبدالرحمن اللي تجمع؟
من هم اللي بيقولون هذا الكلام؟
«أوبن إيه آي» بيلعب دور حقوق الإنسان وما أدري أيش
وأنت السعودي مشبوه، وليش أيش عندكم؟
يا رجال فيه... وترى فيه هذا بالقانون بعضها
يعني حتى في تصدير الأجهزة
فيه قانون اسمه «آي تار» في أمريكا مثلًا
اللي هو حدود على التصدير
لو أنا أروح أشتري مثلًا، وقد صارت لي
في أحد الجهات مع أحد الشركات، نشتري أحد المنتجات
قالوا: أول شيء، لازم نعرف في أيش بستخدمونه؟
ومين بيستخدمه؟
وإذا بيتغيّر المستخدمين تعلموننا
ولازم يكون عندنا وصول عليه
وإذا بتتلفونه؛ لا تتلفونه أنتم، أعطونا إياه احنا نتلفه
لاحظ
وهذا المنتج قد أيش حساس يعني؟
أو هل هو متاح للناس كلها وللا؟
أنا وأنت ما نقدر نشتريه
يعني غالبًا على مستوى الحكومات والشركات
ولو صار بيننا خلاف
تحسب أني بحتكم لقضائك مثلًا؟
أنا ما أثق فيك؛ أثق في قضائك!
نحتكم في لندن، ونحتكم في مدري أيش
ما تقدر، لو بتشتري الجهاز بس
فجأة بيلعون كرت الأخلاقيات
فهل فيه قوانين الحين وللا ما في قوانين؟
فيه قوانين
أقولك أنا الحين يوم جيت بدرس في بريطانيا
جبت قبول بالموت، من جامعة «أكسفورد»
والمشرف موافق، والملحقية موافقة
وأنا موافق وكلهم موافقين
وخلاص ببدأ دراسة
جاوا قالوا: لا، لازم توافق الداخلية البريطانية
أوه!
إيه
أيش تبغى تدرس؟
ذكاء اصطناعي
أها!
صدق والله
والله بغى يروح علي القبول، تخيل!
أنا يوم وصلت الجامعة
لو أني متأخر خمسة أيام؛ راح علي القبول
ترى عشنا بينهم وعلاقاتنا...
ما ودي يبان كأني ضدهم كدول وشعوب
بالعكس تعلمنا هناك وما بيننا وبينهم شيء
بس الموضوع تنافس، طبيعي
وإذا كان عنده كرت بيلعبه
على مستوى التقنيات حتى شوف...
تذكر سالفة «هواوي» مع «دونالد ترامب» على تنافس «5 جي»
فجأة... على تنافس تجاري
طبعًا ما راح يقول تنافس تجاري
قام يرمي لك كل الأسباب الثانية
برضه هذا اللي صار «بايدن»
اللي هو حق المعالجات على الصين
فأي أحد يشتغل في الصين، أي أمريكي
يعني برضه صارت...
إيه حرب تنافسية
وهم بيسمحون لك تتقدم بس إلى حد تكون زبون بس
ما تصير منافس
تبغى تشتري معالجات وللا تبغى تشتري...
أنا صار لي مواقف، كنت بشتري أشياء
والله لو أقول لك إياها تضحك
بس لأنها عادةً تبيعها شركات معدات متقدمة شوي
هي شيء أقرب ما له للفيش، بس فيش خاص
وشيء تافه
قالوا: من أنت؟ وليه تبغاه؟ وأيش تبغى فيه؟
عندي بس فكرة بسويها في البيت، يعني مو ...
لو كنت في أمريكا بتشتريه بيصير عادي؟
إيه ولو بطلبه عبر الإنترنت بيجيني ثاني يوم
والله؟
إيه والله
لو عندي عنوان في أمريكا
كان يمكن طلبت عليه وما سألوني
بس مجرد ما حطيت العنوان السعودية
تعال فيه عب وو
لو أنت مراهق أمريكي يا رجل يمديك تشتري مسدس
سوء استخدام تقنية
فالشاهد قوانين كثيرة مثل كذا
ما تدري أيش فيه يعني
ما راح يسمحون لك تتقدم بهذه السهولة
أنا يوم كنت جالس مع إحدى الشركات
ما ودي أسمّي أسامي، بس نفس الكلام
جاني بملئ فيه قالها
جاء قال: مبروك، الشركة وافقت
أنه الحين تشتغل وتصدّر السعودية
إيه أخيرًا وافقوا؛ الحين بنتكرّم ونبيع لكم أجهزتنا
ملاحظ؟
هذا اللي قاله بملئ فيه
ما بالك اللي يقوله في رأسه
ما بالك اللي يقوله وراء الكواليس
تجي أنا وياك بنبني نموذج لـ«شات جي بي تي»
ونضطر نشتري معالجات
بيجي يقول: تعال، أيش عندك شاري هذه الكمية؟
بنجي نسحب بيانات؛ بيبان حركة المرور
تعال أيش عندكم؟
سوء استخدام التقنية كسلاح ناعم؛ من زمان
أيش الشكل المثالي؟
الشكل المثالي لأيش؟
لضبط الذكاء الاصطناعي على المستوى العالمي بشكل عادل
لازم مثل منظومة دولية، ما في تحيّز
ما يجي أمريكا، وللا بريطانيا، وللا الصين
هي اللي على قولتهم العريف
مثل منظومة الـ«آي إيه إي إيه»
حق انتشار القنابل النووية والأسلحة النووية
زي الـ «يو إن» نظام دولي
بحيث أنه خلاص...
لما المجتمع الدولي يدرس الموضوع ويقول
معليش احنا كدول، وأنت منها عضو
قررنا أنه لازم شوي تفصح عن هذه
غير لما يجيك شركة أجنبية، رئيس تنفيذي أجنبي
قاعد يقول لجهة حكومية في السعودية
مين بيستخدم جهازي
فهذا شكل من الأشكال
يعني يكون مثل الأنظمة الدولية
هذا الـ «يو إن» والـ «واي آي إف إف»
بس شوف مثلًا عندنا في الاتحاد الأوربي
جالسين يسوون قانون اللي هو«إيه آي آكت»
ضبط الذكاء الاصطناعي
وأمريكا ما عندهم شيء محدد لهذا
يعني في الداخل
وكثير يعني، الظاهر 150 شركة في أوربا
اعترضت على فكرة هذا القانون
لأنها جالسة تقيدهم
وبتخلي أمريكا تتفوق بدون نقاش
لأن أمريكا ما عندها
ولذا أصلًا الناس تقول
أن أمريكا متقدمة، لأن ما فيه قانون
فهذا مهم؛ عشان تتقدم معرفيًّا وتتقدم تقنيًّا
وجود القوانين؛ بتحد من الابتكار
وتحد من التطور المعرفي
إذا كان موجود على البعض والبعض لا؛ صح
عشان كذا أقول لازم منظمة دولية على كل العالم
ما ينفع أوربا توقّف وأمريكا تمشي
مره ثانية نظرية الألعاب
الآن الكل مصلحته، وعلاقتهم سباق للهاوية
يعني أنا لو بوقّف؛ هذا ما راح يوقف
بس لو أضمن...
ليش الشركات تقول: أرجوكم حوكمونا؟
لأن قوقل كانت عندها نموذج قبل ما طلعوه، صح؟
كانوا حريصين أنهم يطلعونه بشكل آمن
كانوا يسوون الاختبارات ويدرسون
يقولون طبعًا
إيه بس، هذا قبل سنة
هذاك قال: نظام قوقل واعي
بس كان عندهم نظام من زمان موجود
بس ما استعجلوا في إطلاقه، صح؟
وطلع «شات جي بي تي» 100 مليون في شهر
خطر وجودي بالنسبة لقوقل
خلاص، خلّه وطلّع
بيصير فينا مثل ما صار في «نوكيا»
وللا صار في «كودك»
بكرة يضحكون يقول تذكر قوقل؟
اطلع باللي موجود
من سرعة ما طلعوا؛ حتى كان في خطأ في العرض
يعني مو أنه خطأ واحد أول ما جرب
تصوير الشاشة في تويتر
لا، جاوا قوقل، نادوا الإعلام
قالوا: شوفوا ونموذجنا فيه خطأ
ملاحظ؟
هذا لو تركت الموضوع على...
شوف احنا ما نثق بالشركات مثلًا
وللا القطاع الخاص في البناء
بتخلي المقاولين على كيفهم؟
بيختصر لك، وبيحاول يقلل التكلفة
وبيحاول ياخذ اختصارات
وانت كمستهلك في النهاية
بتشوف البيت من برّا ما...
صعب أنه بصير مهندس أنا عشان أفهم كل البيوت
أشوف الأرخص الظاهر لي
وحتى لو عرفت المخاطر
يمكن أن أقبل بمخاطر أكثر من اللي تقبل فيه
صح
تقبل فيه أنت وللا ذا؟
لا نقبلها في الطب، عندنا هيئة غذاء ودواء
لا نقبلها في النقل
لا نقبلها في أشياء كثيرة
قوقل تقول: حوكمونا أرجوكم
لأنه أنا ودي أسويها بطريقة آمنة
بس ما أقدر إذا غيري يسقط
تخيل كأنك تمشي بالنظام في المرور
والكل يساقط
يعني مثل الأولوية في الدوار
احنا لا، الأولوية للجزوم
صعب أنك تمشي بالنظام وتوقف في إشارة توقّف
يصدمك اللي وراء
إلا
فلازم نظام يحكم الكل
ونتأكد أن كلنا على قولتهم...
أيش يحكمه؟
مثلًا يقول له: لازم تعطيني كيف أنت تحلل البيانات
وكيف تتخذ القرارات كحكومة؟
وللا يقول له: أنك ما يمديك تشتري معالجات بهذا الكم؟
وللا أنه ممنوع أنك تسحب بيانات من هذه الأماكن
وللا بهذا الكم؟
وللا مفترض أنك تفتح لي كل شيء
وأقدر أطلع على كل بياناتك؟
أيش النظام اللي أنت تبغاه؟
أبسط شيء، مو أنت يا «مايكروسوفت»
اللي فجأة تقرر تطلق نموذج مثل هذا على مليار شخص
قبل ما التقنية حقك يتعرض لها مليار شخص
خل نشوف أول
نمشي باختبارات معينة
برضه لازم تراعي
ما ينفع أنا أحاول أجمع البيانات بطريقة قانونية
وأشتري البيانات؛ وغيري قاعد يسحبها ببلاش
مرة ثانية، نقطة «توازن ناش» هنا
رايحه في مكان ما نبغاه
المسار قاعد يروح فيه بناء ذكاء اصطناعي غير آمن
لأنك بتبني ذكاء اصطناعي غير آمن
أسهل من أنك تبني ذكاء اصطناعي آمن
فطبيعي، إذا ما حكمت الناس كأنها مباراة بدون حكم
تخيل مباراة بدون حكم!
والحين ما في حكم؟
في أمريكا، لا
على قولتهم واثقين بالقطاع الخاص
والقطاع الخاص عاد يقول شفنا بلاويه
أجيب مثال هذا قوقل يوم طلع خطأ
تذكر سالفة «إيلون ماسك» يوم أطلق «سايبر ترك»
يوم قال: القزاز هذا ضد الرصاص
لا ويرمي الثانية؛ انكسرت
لاحظ «إيلون ماسك» العبقري المجنون
اللي أسس «سبيس إكس» واشترى تويتر وأسس «تسلا»
وما غلط في مثلًا والله كان في صحفي جايه
وقال: تعال أوريك المختبر
وشوف هذه عندنا وشغالين عليها
لا، هذا صحفيين قاعدين في مكاتبهم
دق عليهم، وقال تعالوا
خلنا أوريكم أنها ما تنكسر
إيه، خلنا أوريكم أنها ما تنكسر
ارم وانكسرت
مثال ثاني بعد
مثال -أيش اسمه لا إله إلا الله- الغواصة «تيتان»
بعد ما انفجرت؛ طلعت في الأخبار
الرجال رمى بالأنظمة عرض الحائط
والاختبارات ما اهتم فيها، وكان متساهل
وكان فيه عنده ثقة كبيرة بالنفس
حتى كان حاط في موقعه
أن الحوكمة هذه ما تنفع للمبدعين
اللي خارج الصندوق؛ دائم اللي جوّا الصندوق يحاربونهم
والكلام فاضي ذا
وما أقول لك هو سواها يعني بلعب الناس
هو دخل ومات بينهم
يعني هو فعلًا تجي نقطة عمياء كذا
ما تقعد تثق بواحد...
يعني أنادي الشركة وأقول لها
أيش رأيك أحوكمك أو لا؟
ما راح يقولك إيه
بيقولك أنا واثق أنه آمن
ولو تحطه في جهاز كشف كذب؛ بيطلع صادق
بس شفناها مليون مرة
مثل برضه مثال «مرسيدس» أول ما أطلقوا نظام الرادار
نادوا الصحفيين قالوا تعالوا
مو بوريّكم السيارة؛ بوريكم الخاصية الجديدة هذه
اللي تخيل لو أنك ماشي في ضباب، وقدامك سيارة وماشي
وبعد سيناريو كذا، الله لا يلوم اللي يلومك
المهم جاوا وعملوا تثبيت وشوية مشت السيارة
«مرسيدس» خل «تسلا» اللي عشرين سنة
باللي 100 سنة
وغلطة الغلطة هذه في عرض للإعلام على خاصية
«تايتنيك» بكبرها...
بنجيب أمثلة تخدم فكرتك
خلني بجيب أمثلة في الجهة الثانية
يعني لو كان في حوكمة؛ لما شفنا «شات جي بي تي»
ما راح نشوفه بهذه السرعة
إيه. ولو كان في حوكمة؛ ما شفنا القيادة الذاتية
أنا شفت أمس أو قبل أمس
«إيلون ماسك» راح حط بث مباشر على تويتر
نختار في الخريطة مكان معين
والسيارة جلست تروح لحالها
ساقت إلى المكان
فالقيادة الذاتية؛ ما كنا بنشوفها بهذه السرعة
حتى «وي» مو حقت قوقل؟
اليوم موجودة في سان فرانسيسكو وموجودة في فينيكس
تاكسي ما فيه سواق نهائيًّا
فهذه موجودة، يعني الناس تستخدمها
حتى ماهي للاختبارات؛ بس لأن المدينة سمحت
فما كنا بنشوف هذا التقدم
لو أنه والله لازم وما أدري أيش
عاد هم ترى فيه حوكمة عليهم
ما تحسب أنه جاء واحد وقرر
أن يحط سيارة ذاتية للقيادة في مدينة معينة
مشى بإجراءات
ولازم يكون فيه راكب وراء المقود، وفيه اختبارات
في بعض المدن فيه مساحة شوي
بس بالعكس المثال هذا
ما أعتقد أنهم تركوها مفتوحة مرة
وللا كان شفنا الوفيات أكثر
فيه قوانين على السيارة ذاتية القيادة في أمريكا
بس أنها قوانين خفيفة
مرتخية شوي أكثر من غيرها
بس ما أقولك أنه لو ما هي موجودة
ما كنا بنشوف سيارة ذاتية القيادة
يمكن ما راح بنشوفها بهذه السرعة
فأنت في مقابل كأنها رهان
وأنت كباحث، ما يخوفك أن القيود تخليك
ما عاد تقدر تبحث أكثر، ما عاد تقدر...
أن التقنية تتوقف، وأن التطور يتوقف
وللا هي التطور اللي احنا ما نبغاه؟
ما يخوفني إذا كلنا نمشي على نفس القانون
إذا كلنا نمشي على نفس القانون
ما نقدر، كيف نقدر؟
كيف كل العالم يقدر يتفق على شيء واحد؟
صعب
هل اتفقوا على النووية؟
اتفقوا على الأشياء البيولوجية؟
مو معناتك ما تحاول ولا بمستحيل
ما راح يكون حل واحد
خلاص انشئ الجمعية هذه
وللا المنظومة هذه؛ وبنحل المسألة
مجموعة قوانين وتقلل الضرر
النقل الحين كم فيه جهة مسؤولة؟
عندك المرور، عندك الجمارك
المواصفات والمقاييس، وجهات كثيرة، ونجم
منظومة كاملة، جهات كتيرة؛ عشان بس...
حتى في البناء؛ فيه المواصفات والمقاييس
فيه وزارة الإسكان، فيه...
الأمانات ومدري أيش
النظام اللي عندهم
إيه. يعني ما راح في الأخير يصير حل بس
خمس موظفين في المكتب وهم يحلون الموضوع
إيه، ما في شك
فالموضوع مثل النووية
مو معناته ما نحاول؛ نحاول
بس كما قلت لك، الشركات ودهم
ما عندهم مشكلة يبنون شيء آمن
بس صعب أني أنا الوحيد اللي ماشي صح والثانيين يتساقطون
فهل مع الحوكمة
إذا افترضنا أنه صارت في منظمة عالمية
أن الحكومات التزمت فيه
أنه عادل إلى حدٍ ما في معظم الدول
هل هذا بيأخر الخطر اللي جاي من الذكاء الاصطناعي
وللا بيحمينا منه؟
احنا المشكلة ما ندري متى بيجي الخطر
صدق والله
ممكن يجي بكرة، ممكن يجي بعد عشر سنين أو بعد مئة سنة
أنت لما تجي تستعد لخطر معين
انت لازم تسأل نفسك
قد أيش أحتاج عشان استعد للخطر ذا؟
لو مثلًا قلت لك بيصدم نيزك بالأرض بعد ستين سنة
متى لازم تستعد للخطر هذا؟
متى؟
قلت لك بعد ستين سنة بيجي
يعني إذا قرّب
إذا قرّب، متى بالضبط؟
لو قلت لك مثلًا نحتاج خمسين سنة عشان...
مثل الاحتباس الحراري
الناس تقول على 2050؛ فتلقى الناس بالكاد يتحركون
إيه هذا مشكلة، الإنسان لازم يصاب
يشعر بالتهديد
إيه عشان يتحرك مثل المدخنين
يعني المدخن
يدري أنه بيموت بالتدخين
يدري، بالعكس...
تدري سوّوا إحصائية سألوا مدخنين قالوا
كم تتوقع الدخان ينقص من عمرك؟
قالوا ثمان سنين، عشر سنين
الرقم الفعلي سبع سنين أو ست سنين
أقل من اللي هم يتوقعونه
يعني خلاص الرسالة وصلت وزيادة
بس متى يتحرك؟ إذا جاته جلطة
وتحرّق وشاف الموت بعيونه
هذا شوف...
الرسالة تجيبه
إيه من جد
مثل، أستغفر الله، أحيانًا أقول أنا
العيال اللي حين بدوا يسوقون
عشان لا يضحك علي بس
أحس ودي يصير له حادث بس ما يصير له شيء
ودي بس يعيش الروعة والخوف
ويدري أنه كان ممكن يروح فيها
بس ما تقعد تسوي السيناريو هذا بالترتيب
نفس الكلام نحتاج تشرنوبلة؛ عشان يقتنعون الناس
فنرجع سؤال، النيزك بيجي بعد ستين سنة
لو قلت لك أنه نحتاج خمسين سنة
عشان نبني نظام يضاده؛ بقول نبدأ اليوم
لو قلت لك نحتاج خمس سنوات؛ أجل خلاص خل نروّق
سؤال الذكاء الاصطناعي
تقول أنت متى بيجي الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق اللي...
ما حد يقدر يعطيك إجابة
ممكن تصير إجابة بكرة، ممكن تصير بعد سنة
ممكن تصير بعد عشر سنين
المثال دايم يضرب في السياق هذا اللي هو القنبلة النووية
كان يعتقدون فطاحل الفيزياء «أينشتاين»
أيش اسمه الثاني؟ نسيت اسمه
يعني كونك تستخرج طاقة من الذرة
يعني كلام فاضي
ثاني يوم الصبح «زيلارد» هذا فكر في فكرة الانشطار
تقريبًا أقل من 24 ساعة
من واحد من أعظم علماء الفيزياء يقول إنه شيء مستحيل
إلى طلعت فكرة أنه ممكن تسويها، وبنوها
فما تقدر تتنبّأ
فأنت الحين إذا ما قدرت تتنبّأ
هو بيجي اليوم وللا بكرة وللا..
فلازم تبدأ بأسرع وقت
بعدين أيش الضرر الحين بالإضافة إلى أنك...
حتى في 2020 نحن كنا نسوي الحلقة
ما كنا نتنبّأ ولا كنت تتصور أنه بيجي «شات جي بي تي 4» بهذا...
لا، ما كنت إيه
فالسرعة... غير أنها تصير تراكمية
إيه بالضبط
فأنت لازم تستعد في أسرع وقت
إذا كنت ما تدري متى بيجي
طيب، برجع إلى نقطة ثانية
هل تعتقد أنه نقدر ننافس؟
ننافس مين؟
ننافس العالم
كسعودية؟
إيه، كسعودية
إيه، نقدر ليش لا
وفقًا للي أنت قبل شوي تقوله
ما أقدر أشتري ولا حاجة
لأني أنا ما أصنع
نحن ما نصنّع معالجات
فأنت تحتاج «جي بي يو إس»
ولا تصنّع هذه أيش يسمونها؟
رقائق
أغلب الأشياء اللي أنتي تحتاجها أجهزة؛ ما تصنعها
تجيك برضه كفاءة، بس لنفرض أن الكفاءة
يعني اللي من علماء أو باحثين
هي معادلة: الكفاءات والموارد
الكفاءات -إن شاء الله- ما عندنا نقص
بالعكس، نحن من الدول اللي نسبة الشباب فيها عالية
ومن ناحية الاقتصاد بالعكس
فيه دول تتمنى اقتصادنا خلنا نقول
وفيه دول مثل اليابان تتمنى شبابنا
هذولاك معدل العمر عندهم عالي؛ ودهم شباب
بس على قولتك
الحين مرحلة الحصول على الموارد هذه
في ظل الظروف هذه اللي قاعدة تصير
ما أحد راح يسمح لك تنافس
فمو معناته أنه لا، قفل وخلينا نبدأ كل شيء من الصفر
ولا خلاص هذه دائم معتمد
تصير عندك خارطة الطريق
أنك كيف تنتقل إلى اعتماد ذاتي على التقنية
مو بشرط أن تكون اعتماد كلي
«وَلَا تَبْسُطْهَا كُلَّ الْبَسْطِ» ولا تجعلها إلى عنقك
في النهاية أنت تعيش مع العالم، تتاجر مع العالم
تشوف أيش الأشياء اللي لك تنافسية اقتصادية فيها وسوّها
وأيش الأشياء اللي لأسباب مثلًا أمنية
حاول تسويها داخليًا
مو بشرط في البداية تكون منافس
بس على الأقل لو انقطعت عنك الخدمة
لأنه عندك بديل
عشان كذا أنا أحيي صراحة الجهود اللي قاعدة تصير
الحين حول بناء نموذج «شات جي بي تي» محلي
لأن اليوم «شات جي بي تي» تقنية
وبكرة بيصير بنية تحتية
خلاص اليوم بدينا نشوف عليها تطبيقات
صح وللا لا؟
يعني تطبيقات مبنية فوق الـ«شات جي بي تي»
فتخيل بعد ما خلاص...
أفرض ما سوينا الجهود هذه عشان نبني نموذج محلي
تطبيقات ونبني فوقها تطبيقات، وبعدين خلاص
بعدين صارت مثل حركة «هواوي» مع الصين
مثل يوم قبل فترة
طالبوا بإلغاء «أبشر» من متجر تطبيقات أبل
فيهم طلعات كذا فجأة
فجأة الرئيس التنفيذي حق أبل وللا...
«أوبن إيه آي» ما كان داخل السعودية في البداية
إيه صح، دوبه ماله إلا كم أسبوع
إيه إلا قبل أسبوعين
الظاهر يوم شافونا نبني قالوا
خلاص هوّنا، لا تبنون استخدموه
أنا ما أدري أيش السبب
بس أنت لازم عندك السياسة هذه اللي يصير عندك
على الأقل نظام يكفيك
وبعدين ممكن تدخل تنافسية تجارية فيه
عاد على حسب أمور أخرى
وين تشوف احنا اليوم؟
وين نشوف احنا اليوم؟ والله
شوف من ناحية كفاءات وكذا موجودة
احنا ينقصنا الحين مثل ما قلت لك
مفروض أنه جامعين البيانات من زمان وكذا
قبل ما يصير كذا هذه العين عليها الحين
الحين بيصير الموضوع جمع البيانات أصعب
ما أقدر أقيّم صراحة بس
نقدر بس مثل ما قلت لك التحديات هذه
الحصول على الموارد والبيانات
بندخل في عراك مع جهات ثانية
خارج تحكمنا
طيب، على المخاطر هل أنت تشوف
أن الذكاء الاصطناعي بيأخذ الوظائف؟
هذا تشوفه لا محالة بيصير
وأن هذا أصلًا لا يصنف من ضمن مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
سواءً الأطباء، المحامين، المحاسبين، المحللين الماليين
كل هذه الوظائف، الكتّاب
هذه كلها بتروح، وهذا ما لها علاقة بمخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
وللا أنت تشوف أنها أصلًا ما بتروح، وللا كيف تشوفها؟
هي ممكن تبني ذكاء اصطناعي
يسوي أي شيء يسويه الإنسان
ما في شيء نظريًّا يقول لك هذا مستحيل
كما قلت لك مثال سرعة الضوء
مخك في النهاية آلة، يعني وين...؟
وأشياء كثيرة قلنا مستحيل تسويها الآلة؛ وتسويها
الظاهر قد قلتها في اللقاء السابق
أن الكمبيوتر كانت وظيفة يعني
الشاهد، أنت الحين التطور صار كذا
خلني أقول لو بترتب ذكاء الكائنات
احنا هنا، والآلة كانت مثل «الكانبيبا»
صارت ذكاء الحشرة، صارت ذكاء الحيوان
تقرّب من ذكاء الإنسان
ويوم من الأيام تتعداه
تقدر تسوي أي شيء يسويه الإنسان
فأنا أتوقع أنه ممكن يوم الأيام نوصل لمرحلة
الآلة يمكن تسوي أي شيء
معاد فيه حاجة لليد العاملة
صدق الله
فالخطر مو أنه بيشيل الوظائف هذه كليًّا
الخطر أنه يجي من دون ما نستعد
للمرحلة الانتقالية والاقتصاد الجاي
لأن شكل الاقتصاد المستقبلي في ظل ذكاء اصطناعي خارق
يقدر يسوي أي شيء أنت تسويه
ما تقدر حتى تستوعب الحين
مثل لما أجي أشرح الاقتصاد اليوم لواحد قبل 400 سنة
اقتصاد الحين معقد و...
مو 400 سنة، لو تشرحه قبل لا يجي الإنترنت
إيه بالضبط
ما تقدر تتخيل أنه عايشين بهذا...
يعني لما أحد يقولك تقدر تفصل النت
لأن الحياة بتتعطل
أنا أذكر وأنا صغير أقول: ليش ما الحكومة تطبع فلوس؟
تحس موضوع سهلات
يعني فرق عن نظام اقتصاد المقايضة
بتعطيني وأعطيك. بعطيك رز، تعطيني تمر
الحين نظام اقتصادي معقّد ومربوط بالناتج المحلي
والأحداث العالمية
وكان مرتبط بالذهب وصار مرتبط بالدولار
يعني يتهيأ لنا فاهمين؛ بس خلاص تعودنا
إيه. الاقتصاد الحين لما تجي تشرحه لواحد قبل 300 سنة
مو مستوعب أيش الورقة ذي؟
بعدين ما صارت ورقة، صارت...
أرقام تزيد وتنقص و
صارت مجرد الرقم على الجهاز
إي ومالك بأجل
النظام الاقتصادي هذا
مرة غريب بالنسبة لواحد قبل 100 سنة
نفس الكلام إذا وصل الذكاء الاصطناعي الخارق
اللي يسوي كل الوظائف
أنت تحتاج نظام اقتصادي مختلف تمامًا
يعني الرأسمالية والشيوعية والإشتراكية ذي
هذه كأنها مثل المقايضة قبل
لأن كلها معتمدة على رأس مال ويد عاملة
صح
إذا ما في أيدي عاملة
ليش أصرف رأس مال، وأيش فلوس
نلعب على بعض
أعطيك فلوس عشان ترجع تعطيني...
والناس أيش تسوي وقتها حتى إذا ما تشتغل؟
تخيل أنك ما تشتغل أيش تسوي؟
والله شوف أحس لو جد جاء
بيقول: تصدق يا إبراهيم أنك قاعد تشتغل؟
هذا تسميه شغل؟
تروح المكتب وبريد إلكتروني واجتماعين وتجي هلكان
الحين يتهيأ لك اللي قاعد تسويه هذا شغل؟!
راح اليوم، وهو سوّى ثلاث اجتماعات مع بعض
لا ودي آخذ إجازة
وبعدين الشغل لجد جدك
كان الظاهر من لما بدأ يمشي كان يشتغل
إلى أن ما خلاص ما يقدر يتحرك
صح
صح ولا لا؟
طبيعي
بعدين صرنا نشوف لا، الصغار مفروض ما يشتغل إلا بعد عمر معين
إلى عمر معين ممنوع أنه يشتغل
بعدين بعد فترة معينة إلى عمر معين
مفروض أنه ما يشتغل
خلاص يجيك التقاعد
وقعدت حتى أول ما سمعت التقاعد وأنا صغير
قلت: شلون يعني خلاص ما يعطون راتب للأبد؟
ما يشتغل؟ يعطونه فلوس؟
قاعد أيش يسوي
ولا شيء يطفي اللمبات
ويدفع الأكياس
فالفجوة هذه كل ما لها تصغر
الحين أنا ولدي في الجامعة
وإلى الآن مو متوقع حتى أن يصرف على نفسه
أنت خلّص جامعة، وإلى ما تخلّص جامعة 2023-2024
وبعد بنعطيك استراحة سنة تدور على وظيفة
فكل مالها الفجوة بتقل
حاليًا عندنا أنظمة كثيرة «ساند» و«حافز»
الأنظمة دي اللي تساعد
ضمان اجتماعي، التقاعد
أشياء كثيرة حتى لو ما تشتغل
خذ فلوس، دخل أساسي
والإنسان ما أدري عاد...
بس أنه بيصير إن الإنسان ما يشتغل
الإنسان الفاضي؛ مصيبة
الفراغ قد تعوّذ منه حتى الرسول
فالفراغ مصيبة على الإنسان وعلى المجتمع
صح، بس أنك تقعد تشغل نفسك بشغل كعمل
بضرب لك مثال مرة ثانية
أنا أقدر أقول لولدي مثلًا تعال ساعد في البيت
مو عشان أحتاجه بس
مثل مثال قد قاله برضه الدكتور «أحمد قاسم»
أذكر في الظاهر بودكاست
اللي أول كان الإنسان يتحرك كثير
الآن مع قل الحركة ونوعية الأكل اللي ناكلها الحين
صرنا نروح النادي ونسوي الحركة هذه اللي نعوض عن...
صح، إلا إيه
فيمكن يصير فيه مثل نادي وظيفي
روح وعش كأنك تشتغل يعني عش الدور
فهذا المجال الاقتصاد اللي ما فيه فلوس، وما فيه يد عاملة
هذه يسمونه اللي هو الاقتصاد ما بعد الندرة
اللي هو مجال كذا فيه ناس في الاقتصاد
يحاولون يتخيلونه
عجيب
إيه مثل الرأسمالي والشيوعية يقولك
مثلًا: مين اللي يحدد توزيع الموارد؟
الملكية عند مين؟
أيش دور الحكومة في الاقتصاد؟
هنا يختلفون المدارس الاقتصادية
الاقتصاد ما بعد الندرة
ما يرتكز على الملكية؛ يرتكز على الوصول
خلاص معاد فيه أحد يمتلك شيء
أنت أعطيك قدرة للوصول إلى أشياء
هذا على أفتراض بنينا الاقتصاد آمن
وانتقلنا له بطريقة سليمة
بس فيه تصورات للاقتصاد المستقبلي هذا
أنه خلاص، مثلًا أنت...
مثل ما قلنا الآلة بيصير هدفها
أنها تستكشف أهدافك وتحاول ترضيك
فبيصير دخلك من أنك مثلًا تشارك بياناتك
أو أنك مثل ما برامج التواصل الاجتماعي هذه
تحاول أنهم يتنافسون على انتباهك وتركيزك
تصير وللا لا؟
هذه عملتك بتصير
يعني في الذكاء الاصطناعي من مصلحته أنه يفهمك
فيقول: تمام، خلاص لو تسمح لي
أوصل لبياناتك بطريقة معينة
هذه تعطيك نقاط إضافية
راح تعطيك مثلًا أشياء تميزك عن غيرك
أو مثلًا أنك تشتغل في أشياء كذا
الإنسان لا زال يحب أنها تكون إنسانية
حتى بعض الأشياء المصنوعة يدويًّا
تحس أن لها قيمة أعلى من مصنوعات آخرى
مع أنه تقدر تصنعها بالآلة وأرخص
فيه تصورات لكيف ممكن يكون الاقتصاد
قائم على أتمتة كاملة على كل الوظائف
وأيش أعراضها النفسية؟
مثلًا فيه اختبارات الآن مثل الـ «الدخل الأساسي العالمي»
فيه كذا دولة جربتها
اللي هو نظام أني أعطيك دخل أساسي من دون أي شروط
بدون ما تشتغل وبدون ما تسوي أي شيء
حتى مو مطلوب منك تبحث عن وظيفة
اللي كون أنك بس مواطن تملك حق في الصحة
لك حق في التعليم؛ هذا دخل أساسي
بل جربوه في فنلندا وانتهت التجربة، بس ما...
إيه جربوه في فنلندا، جربوه في كندا
وجربوه في مدينة الظاهر في أمريكا وكذا
فالآن نتائجهم متعارضة
هم يسوون التجارب هذه ليش؟
أولًا يشوفون هل مثلًا نفع من ناحية صحية ونفسية؟
هل ساعد...
هل رجع الشخص بحث عن وظيفة؟
هل فرق ما فرق؟
هل فاد الاقتصاد؟ هل هل
على حد علمي النتائج إلى الآن
ما في اتفاق كامل عليها
أيش رأيك في مقالة نشرها «مارك أندرسون»
كان مفادها: أن خطر الذكاء الاصطناعي مبالغ فيه
وأنه مثله مثل أي تقنية تجي للبشرية
والناس تبدأ تهول منها، وفي الأخير يطلع عادي
وتقدر تاخذها من بداية أي تقنية دخلت
الراديو، التلفزيون إلى البلوكتشين مؤخرًا
إلى الحين الذكاء الاصطناعي
فهل تشوف منطقي هذه المروية؟
طيب أنا أقول له: «آلن تورينق» قال خطر
هذا «أينشتاين» حقنا؛ فصفيه
كأن بناخذها بالأسامي
إيه، بس أن كل تقنية تجي؛ الناس تخاف منها
وبعدين يطلع أنه عادي
أنت ما تقدر تقيس
التقنية هذه ما تسبب خطر وجودي
مثل القنابل النووية وللا مثل الأسلحة البيولوجية
أنا أقول أن هذه التقنية
خلنا نقارع الحجة بالحجة
حجة السلطة، ما قالوا وما قالوا
لا كل واحد له رأيه
أقولك حاليًا
اللي وصلوا له الباحثين في المجال
وكما قلت لك فيه نظريات حتى مثبتة
هذه نظرية التعامد
هذه نظرية (Instrumental convergence)
اللي هي مجرد ما يعرف هدفك
يعرف أهداف وسيطة لك كثيرة
نظرية الألعاب
تقدر تتنبأ وتقيس
قلت لك معادلة بسيطة
اثنين مختلفين بالأهداف؛ الأذكى بيفوز
فأنت يا أنك تحافظ على ذكائك أعلى منه
وللا تحافظ على أهدافكم تكون متوائمة
ففيه طريقة ثانية
أو تقتله
على أساس ما راح تخطر على باله، وعلى أساس بتقدر
يعني هذا اللي أقولك بتقتله؛ هذه بالتصميم
أنت مجرد ما تعطيه هدف
أكيد هو يعرف إذا انطفأ، فما راح يسوي هدفه
هو أذكى منك ويتغلّب عليك
ولو يدري أنك بتكتشفه؛ بيقتلك
يتمسكن حتى يتمكن
يمكن يكذب عليك
يكذب إلى أن يوصل نقطة؛ يعرف أنك خلاص
ما تقدر تفصله، انتشر
فهي ماهي مبالغ فيها
هو بالعكس أنا شوف الناس مهونينها بزيادة
والله؟
شوف أغلب الناس اللي على الأقل
أنا احتكيت معه في الموضوع
اللي في صف أنها ماهي بخطر
ما تلقاه بحث وقرأ في المجال كفاية
يعني تعطيه أشياء اللي مرة
«إيه بي سي» ترى اللي قلتها له في المجال
«إيه بي سي» النظرية هذه أساس الأساس
قلت لك الوضع هذا
نقطة «توازن ناش»
حاليًا قاعدة تمشي في أننا نبني ذكاء اصطناعي غير آمن
احنا بس ودنا نغيّر المعادلات بشكل بسيط
بحيث تضمن أن كل الشركات من صالحها
أنها تبني ذكاء اصطناعي آمن
ما بيطلع لك أشرار خارج النظام؟
حتى لو سويت نظام آمن؟
عاد هذه مشكلة مختلفة
فيه مشكلة أنه ذكاء الاصطناعي يتمرد
فيه مشكلة أنه خلاص بنينا ذكاء اصطناعي آمن
كيف نضمن استخدامه بشكل سليم
وهي تقريبًا يمكن حلقتنا السابقة
اللي فيه مبادئ، الشفافية
المساواة والمسؤولية
وكيف تضمن أن تبنيه بطريقة صحيحة، إلى آخره
هذه نحيل المشاهدين على الحلقة السابقة
أنه كيف تبني ذكاء اصطناعي آمن؟
باختصار: مجموعة مبادئ نطبقها
في التطوير والتبني والاستخدام
فخطرين مختلفين
شكرًا جزيلًا
العفو، حيّاكم الله
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لوهاب موسى في التصوير
ومحمد الحسن في الهندسة الصوتية
وتحرير الحلقة محمد نور شمّت
وفي التلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج أيمن الحمادي
وفي إدارة التحرير أسيل با عبدالله
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
أنا شفت لك أيش اسمه؟
لقاءك في «سيدتي»
متى كان قريب هو؟
قبل شهرين أو ثلاثة
فكنت ضايف السؤال اللي هل يمدي...
تحمل؟
إيه بس، مو يمكن أن يمدي الإنسان يتزوج آلة؟
نظريًّا يمدي صح؟
يمدي يحب وحده آلة، الحين هذه آلة
يمديه يتزوج آلة، ويحبها
لأنه يمديه بس بالكلام
فتفهمه وتسولف معها، صح؟
يمديه يحب آلة، تقريبًا يعني
ما أدري، ممكن فيه واحد يحب آلة؟
ما أعرف بصراحة
لا أيش دعوة
إذا الآلة تقدر تفهمك، مثل فيلم «هير»
أنت تتذكره؟
إيه، هل ممكن تكوّن علاقة عاطفية مع شيء غير إنسان؟
ممكن
يعني إذا تفهمك تقدر تنكت وتضحك لك
أحس مرة سهل
وإذا كان الشيء هذا خل نقول
صورة رمزية لشخص تعرفه، خل نقول مثلًا...
أوه طيب حلو
فمعناته تقدر تحب آلة عاطفيًا
أنا شوف أنه ممكن، غير مستبعد
أنا ممكن الحين عبدالرحمن عندك بيانات ما شاء الله بالنت
وصورك موجودة وصوتك موجود
وخل نقول الحين أقدر أحاكي صوتك
الحين مع تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي
قدر يبني لي شخصية لعبدالرحمن رمزية
وخل نقول لأهلك الحين بدوا يستخدمونه
وبعد عمر طويل توفيت، لا قدر الله
بيكونوا علاقة معك، بالعكس ذكريات بتتراكم
فتخيل مثلًا واحد جاء وأخذ القرص الصلب ومسح محتوياته
هل أنا ذبحت عبدالرحمن؟
ما دخلنا فيها أخلاقيات التعامل مع روبوتات
مشكلة والله
بس فعليًا يمديك تقع في هذه العلاقة العاطفية معاه
فيمدي أصلًا الشركات تصير تسوّي
بنات تحبهم أو رجال يحبونهم البنات
يعني عادي آلات كلهم، صح؟
الحين فيه شركات يقدمون ترى خدمة مثل هذه
اللي يحاول يبني لك صورة رمزية
ما أدري بس أحس أنه مستقبل مرة
مستقبل معطوب
شوف اللي قاعدين نسولف عنه هذا الحين
شيء في الفلسفة يسمونه الإنسانية
اللي متى يكون هذا الشيء إنسان؟
ويعامل بطريقة إنسانية؟
ومتى ما يكون إنسان؟
يعني الحين افرض أنك اكتشفت أني مثلًا روبوت
طاح الكاس هذا وانجرحت وصب زيت وللا شيء
صدق الله
هل بتذبحني مثلًا؟
وللا تقول: لا هذا لعب علينا؛ حرقوه
ونفس الكلام مثال الصورة الرمزية اللي قلت لك إياه
فأنت هنا تعريفك للإنسان
هو اللي يحدد تعاملك الأخلاقي معه
عشان كذا الناس قاعدين يحاولون يفهمون مسألة الوعي
هل الروبوت إذا وصل لمرحلة...
هل يعي؟
شوف أنا بجاوب جوّا البودكاست وللا برّا البودكاست
عشان فيه شخصيتين
سوّي مثل كذا ومثل كذا؛ واحنا نقرر
طيب
أفضل طريق أنك تستوعب الوعي
اللي هي أول شيء افهم...
على الأقل الطريقة اللي أنا فهمته فيها
اللي هو الوعي المحدّد
هل أنت واعي مثلًا أنه فيه لسانك جوّا فمك وأسنان؟
هل أنت واعي برجلك؟
أنفاسك الحين قاعدة تطلع وتطلع؟
لاحظ، كل ما قلت شيء
كل ما أنتقل تركيزك له واستوعبت
أول كنت ناسي وناسي أنك ناسي
شفت الفرق بين أنك مستوعب الشيء هذا
و أنك ما أنت مستوعبة؟
هذا نسميه الوعي
في وحدة حتى قد جاءها الظاهر جلطة في المخ أو سرطان
ناسي والله
فأثّر في جزئية في المخ؛ خلاها تشوف بس ما تستوعب
وسوّوا معها تجارب مثيرة
جابوا صورتين لبيتها
وواحد يحترق وواحد لا
وبالنسبة لها، هي تشوف البيتين مثل بعض
كل البيتين سليمات
فلما تسألها أي بيت ودك تسكنين فيه؟
دائمًا تشير للبيت اللي ما ينحرق
مع أنك لو تسألها تقول نفس الشيء
ولو ترمي عليها كورة
من الجهة اللي هي تشوف فيها وما تستوعب
توخر؛ بس ما تدري ليش وخرت
فهذا الجزء اللي اللي يخليك تستوعب أنك مستوعب
هي النقطة اللي يسمونها الواعي
إلى الآن في بحر فلسفة
وهذه يسمونها «المشكلة السهلة للوعي»
وهي متى تتحول البيولوجيا إلى وعي
فيه «المشكلة الصعبة للوعي»
اللي يفسّر الشعور الداخلي هذا
وضروري سؤال مسألة الوعي هذا في الروبوتات
لأنه بيحدد كيف تتعامل بطريقة أخلاقية؟
لو تلاحظ أنت الحين
أيش اللي يخليك تتعامل مع شيء بطريقة أخلاقية أكثر من الثاني؟
ترى على قدر قد أيش هو وعي
الحيوان، غير النبات، غير الحشرات، غير الإنسان
فتحديد إنسانيتك هذا مهم في تحديد الأخلاق
هذا بعد برضه تحدي ثاني
كيف تخلي الروبوت يتعامل معك بطريقة أخلاقية؟
كيف تبرمجه على الأخلاق؟
لأنك لو بتقول له: يلا أبغاك تعامل الإنسان بشكل أخلاقي
أول تحدي بتواجهه اللي هو أيش الإنسان؟
اللي قلناه قبل شوي
يعني أنا إنسان، أنت إنسان
طيب الجنين ماهو إنسان؟
فيه ديانات حتى قبل منع الحمل؛ حرام يعتبر قتل
حتى بعد ما يعني...
ففيه ناس يقولون لك الإنسانية هذه درجات
مثلًا هل الميت دماغيًا؟
إيه صدق
أيش تسوي فيه؟
الجثة هل هو إنسان؟
طب إذا مو بإنسان؛ هل أعامله مثل الكرسي؟
فهي درجات، يعني واحد بيقول لك
الجثة أقل من الجنين، أقل من العاقل البالغ
برضه فيه العاقل البالغ المجرم
ممكن تذبحه، صح؟
صح
ممكن تعدمه إعدام، صح؟
فأنت الآن لو تقول للروبوت يلا أحمِّ البشرية
بيقول لك هذا بيموت
بتقول له: لا أصبر، فاهم غلط
هذا لازم يموت
إيه هذا لازم يموت لأنه فيه ارتباط عندنا
بين إنسانية الشخص وأخلاقه
أنت كل ما سويت شيء غير أخلاقي
كأنك سلبناك شوي من إنسانيتك
عشان كذا في الحروب تلقى أول خطوة
تشيطن خصمك، وتنزل لمنزلة الحيوان
فمشكلة شائكة
كيف بس تقول للروبوت أبغاك تحمي الإنسان؟
أحس بيقول: يا رجال أنت عرّف ذكر وأنثى، وبعدين تعال نتقابل
الحين صاروا ملخبطين
بكرة بيجيك روبوت ويقول (Identify as human)
والله، وللا العكس يجيك إنسان يقول (Identify as robot)
إيه
نضحك الحين، بس ترى اللي قاعد يصير أشياء
ممكن نلتغي بكرة
مثل ما يقولك: فيه درجات طيف
فيه طيف بين الإنسان والآلة
وإذا اندمجوا الآلة والإنسان
خل نقول مثلًا هذه الشرائح اللي قاعدة تزرع في المخ
إيه
خل نقول زادت الشرائح
تخيل إيه شرائح، بعدين إذا صار فيها ذكاء اصطناعي
بعدين إذن هي تتحكم في عقلي
تخيل قد سوينا فيك عمليات إلى أن صرت تقريبًا
ثلاثة أرباعك أجهزة
مصيبة
هل لازلت عبدالرحمن؟
هل الحين تستحق معاملة أخلاقية مختلفة؟
لو بدلناك جزئية جزئية إلى ما صرت كلك روبوت؟
بس نفس ذكريات عبدالرحمن، نفس مشاعره
نفس هيئته، نفس كل شيء
ولو قدرت تعرف الوعي وتحطه فيه
بيصير أنا أنا
ترى الوعي مرة ثانية
كيف عرفت أني أنا واعي؟
أنت مفترض الحين أن أنا وعي؟
إيه
من تصرفاتي صح؟
أنت بتحكم بتصرفات
بنوصل لمرحلة الروبوت بيتصرف بطريقة
ما تقدر تفرق بينها وبين الواعي
فعلى أي أساس تقول إبراهيم واعي وهذا مو واعي؟
إذا كان كل الأشياء اللي حققها إبراهيم، حققها الروبوت
بتواجه مشاكل النظرات الأخلاقية هذه
عجيب والله
طبعًا أيمن غير مقتنع بخطر الذكاء الاصطناعي نهائيًّا
يقول أنه لا يستنبط الحديث؛ معناته ماهو ...
لا يستنبط؟
أتمنى غيرنا رأيك شوي اليوم
غيّر رأيه، أقنعك يمكن طيب؟
عندي سؤال
نحن نخاف دائمًا من الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنه يتهجم علينا
هل أقدر أعلمه فكرة الإله
و أقول له أنا إلهك -استغفر الله- فيصير يعرف القوانين
اللي كيف يتعامل فيها علاقة الإله بعبده
فيصير ما عاد يقدر يسوي لك شيء
خلاص أي إنسان استغفر الله
يعني على أساس البشر ما يعصون الله الحين
إيه بس لأن عندهم الإرادة
فهل هو عنده إرادة؟
فلو وضحت له القوانين هذه حق العلاقة ما بين الإله
أنت كيف تعطيه إرادة هذا طيب؟
شوف الإرادة بعد سؤال فلسفي ثاني
نفس الكلام الحين...
خلّي عنده احتمالية 90%
يعني مثل ما «آلن تورينق» دف تعريف الذكاء إلى اختبار
اللي قد أيش أنا أقدر أفرق بينه وبين ذكاء إنسان
الإرادة تقدر تحاول تسحبها من الفلسفة للعلم
تقول: قد أيش أقدر أتنبّأ بتصرفاتك؟
إذا أنا أقدر أتنبّأ بتصرفاتك 100%
فوين الإرادة؟ صح؟
على أساس هذا التعريف الحين
أنت إذا أعطيته إرادتك قد تنبّأ فيها 100%
فأما أنك أنت زرعت فيه أنه يعصيك
أو أنها ماهي بإرادة، خلاص أتمتة...
بس مرة ثانية إذا أنت بتبرمجه
بحيث أنك مرة تكون متنبأ فيه
فأكيد بيكون محصور في ذكائك أنت
ما يقدر يتعداه
غير النظام الحين اللي قاعد يتعلم
ويقدر يتخطئ ذكائك
بس إذا ما خليته 100% خليته 90%
90% أيش هو إرادة؟
إيه
أعتقد أنه كما قلت لك مجرد ما يصير فيه
جزء اختلاف هو عنده تفوق بسيط
بيتفوق على المدى البعيد
سهلة والله المعادلة، بس ما أدري ليش ما أنتم مقتنعين؟
أذكى منك وأهدافك مختلفة عنه
مثل مثال الشطرنج، ارجع له
أقدر أتنبّأ أنه بيفوز علي؟
بيصير الإنسان معقد، هذه هي الفكرة
يعني ولا هو محدد ذكاء الإنسان
فأنا ممكن أفوز عليك في الشطرنج
بس أنا أقدر برضه أميّز أشياء باقي ما تعلمت عليها
إيه بس هذاك شوي كلام عاطفي
في كل مكان
إيه عاطفي
عاطفي؟
إيه الإنسان مميز، ليش مميز؟
من عمر الدنيا واحنا نميز نفسنا
أول كنا الأرض مركز الكون
بعدين قلنا: لا المجموعة الشمسية هي مركز المجرة
بعدين قلنا: المجرة مركز الكون
حتى ميّزنا كصنف؛ طلعنا فرع في شجرة الحياة
والآلة مستحيل تكون أذكى مني بكذا
مستحيل تحفظ، مستحيل...
أيش اللي يميزك؟ أنت كمخ إنسان حتى بطيء
بطيء من سرعة الحسابات بالحاسب
ألف ضعف الظاهر
وهو بالطبع متفوق عليك بكل مجال
وتنسى وتنام، وهو ما ينام ولا ينسى
سرعة المعرفة اللي يقدر يحصل عليها
بس مو هي... ما أظن أن اللي يقول
أنه ما راح يتفوق على الذكاء البشري
يقصد أنه...
هو يسلّم بأن هو متفوق علينا في مجالات كثيرة
هو متفوق في الحفظ، متفوق في أنه يستنبط أنماط معينة
إذا كان عنده بيانات ضخمة
بس أيش رأيك باللي يقول أن كل الذكاء الاصطناعي
اللي احنا واصلينه الآن
هو بسبب أنه يتعلم عن طريق الاستقراء بس
وأنك أنت قدمت له بيانات مرة كثير ضخمة
100% أن قدرته على التخزين أفضل مني
100% أن قدرته على استحضارها أفضل مني
فهو بالتالي قادر أنه يطلع أنماط معينة
بس هو ما يستطيع أن يتعلم إلا بالاستقراء بس
ما يقدر يقيس الأشياء وكل هذا
يعني القياس والاستنباط
وكيف يستنبط الشيء خلاف النص الظاهر، فهمت علي؟
هو هذا مصدر المعرفة حقته
الوحيد
تمام بس ليش ما يقدر يستنبط؟
أنت قاعد تستنبط، مع أن عندك حواس
وتقرأ وتشوف وتسمع
ومن المدخلات هذه؛ أنت عندك برضه مخ منطقي
يحكّم ويستنتج ويستنبط
يعني ما في شيء يمنع
إيه بس...
هذا الشيء اللي قلته للشباب قبل ما أدخل الاستديو
كنت أتناقش معهم على نفس السالفة
وكنت أقولهم أيش اللي بيخلي الذكاء الاصطناعي
يفكر في يوم الأيام يصحى ويأخذ بُن من الأشجار
ياخذه ويحمّسه ويحطه في الماء
وبعدين يستنبط أن هذه قهوة؛ يلا خل نشربها
أيش اللي بيحفزه لهذا التصرف؟
هذا اللي أقصده، أن هو مهما وصل
هو بيتفوق عليّ في الكثير من الأشياء
بس 100% أن فيه أشياء بتغيب عنه
عادي أنه أبطئ، عادي أني أنسى
أنت ليش مفترض أنه بيسوي شيء؟
كأنك تقول مثلًا
أيش اللي بيخلي الطيارة تسوّي عشّة وتقعد فيها
مع أن الطيارة تصميم مختلف جدًّا عن العصفور
فيه أشياء ما يقدر يسويها
لأن أنا تصميم مختلف عنه، وهو تصميم مختلف عني
ففكرة التفوق علي بكل الأشياء
هذه اللي أظن أن عندي مشكلة فيها
أكيد يتفوق علي بكثير من الأشياء
أنا ما عندي مشكلة فيها
بيصير أذكى مني، يحفظ أحسن مني
يؤدي العمليات أحسن مني، يكتب أفضل مني
بس وارد أن فيه جوانب بكرة أنا بعرفها
هو ما يقدر يا إبراهيم فيها
فهذا أقصد، أن التفوق الكامل
إيه، وأنا أقول لك هنا: البيّنة على من ادعى
احنا الحين في موضع لا إرادي
احنا ما ندري هل بيقدر وللا ما يقدر؟
بس أنا أقول لك نظريًّا
ما في شيء يمنع
وقاعدين نشوف الرتم كل ما له يقترب
أنت تقول مستحيل
«هٰاتُوا بُرْهٰانَكُمْ»
أقدر أثبت لك الحين
أنك لم تقدر تنزل تحت الصفر كلفن؛ ما تقدر
ما تقدر تمشي على سرعة الضوء نظريًّا
فلما أشوفك قاعد تبني مركبة
وللا هذه الآلة الحركية الأبدية
بقول لك: الطاقة لا تنفى، ولا تاخذ من عدم
أيش قاعد تسوي أنت؟
لا تفكر تبني آلة تولّد لك طاقة من عدم
مثبت ومنتهين وقاضين
هذا مبني على حدس وشعور وميول لأنك إنسان وبشر
يتهيأ لك أنك أنت مثل «إيلون ماسك»
عندك ثقة زايدة بنفسك
انحياز ذاتي
أنا والله العظيم لو واحد جاء و أثبت لي
قال: يا إبراهيم أثبتنا أنه...
مثل فيه واحد «راجو بنروز» واحد رياضي معروف
قال: أن الوعي في المخ يستخدم ميكانيكا الكم
بس عليها ملاحظاته وكل الأشياء
بس أن عنده فرضية
فأنت لو جيت أثبت لي أن الواعي اللي في المخ
قاعد يسير على المستوى الكمي
بعدين جيت قلت لي: الآلة هذه ما تستخدم الكم
على الأقل أنك بتجاريه
فيه منطق الحين هذا
هذا قدر يسوي شيء عشانه مبني على الكم
وهذا ما فيه كم
فمستحيل يوصل له
هذا حجة
بس مو أحس أنه ما يقدر
هذا كلام...
بصراحة أظن أن كلنا في نفس المنطقة
أنا اللي أحتاج إثبات وأنت بعد تحتاج إثبات
لا لا، هو يقدر...
ما يقدر يثبت أن الذكاء الاصطناعي يقدر يصحى بيوم
يسوي قهوة من رأسه
وللا يخترع طبخة من رأسه
بس ليش ما يسرّع الإنترنت طيب
بس الآن يقدر يطبخ طبخة من رأسه
الآن، اليوم صح؟
إيه يقدر يطلع وصفات
من رأسه
إيه بس ليش؟
عنده بيانات
عنده وصفات سابقة
لا لا، من وصفات غير سابقة
يسوي وصفة لم تخلق من قبل، أو وجبة لأول مرة
فهو أيش اللي بيخليه يسوي القهوة لأول مرة؟
خلني بنظّرها شوي
أنت كيف تقدر تستنتج أهداف الذكاء الاصطناعي؟
فيه على الأقل طريقتين: أما من اللي صممه
أو من وين ورثه
لو أنا مثلًا صممت ذكاء اصطناعي
وصممته على أساس أن يقوم ويسوي قهوة
فأكيد أنه يقدر يسويها
أو المثال الثاني أني...
طبعًا هو يقصد بالقهوة أتوقع
أن البشرية ما كانت تعرف شيء اسمه قهوة
فهو راح شاف كذا شجرة وشاف بُن
ليش ما اختار شجرة ثانية؟
بعدين جرّب، بعدين شاف
بعدين طلع طعم؛ فابتكر
يعني مثل كذا، فجلس
هم مروا بمراحل كانوا يأكلونها، يعني نفترض بالسردية
اللي تقول أنهم أخذوا البُن لحاله وكلوه
فعندها، كان مو حلو كفاية
فخلونا نحطه بالماء
فهذه فكرة القهوة
نحطه مع السكر
فهذه السلسلة من الأشياء اللي تطلع بشكل غير معقول
بدون سابق تجربة من العدم تقريبًا
يعني ما كانوا البشر تشربه
أنا ماني دكتور
ولا بتفلسف...
لا، الموضوع فلسفي وجدلي وفيه اختلاف
ترى فيه ناس ماخذين جائزة «نوبل»
ويشوفون أنه مو خطر، فيه
أي شيء تظن أنه ابتكره من العدم
فهو اللي أنا أقوله، أنه مو من العدم
هو لأن عنده حصيلة تجارب غابت عنك
لأنك أنت تنسى بعد، وهو ما ينسى
حاضر كل شيء بنفس الحضور
للشيء اللي اكتسب قبل دقيقة أو قبل 200 سنة
أنت قاعد تأنسن الآلة
لا تفكر الآلة أنها بتصير تشبه لك وللا...
لو تخيلنا دائرة العقول البشرية
مقابل دائرة كل العقول بما فيها الآلة
قد تكون نقطة في دائرة كبيرة
ممكن فجأة نقطة هنا فيه آلة أهدافها
أنت ليش تحب القهوة؟
لأنها تكيّفك بالنهاية صح وللا لا؟
يمكن اللي يكيّف الروبوت هذا شيء ثاني
فأبغاك تشوف شيء ثاني
مادة ثانية اللي تزيد مكافأته هذه
قد لا تعلمها
إيه، كما أنت، ما كنت أدري عن القهوة
أول شيء، من الاستكشاف
استكشفت أن هذا شيء طيب
خلنا نبحر فيه زيادة
هل تتوقع أن الإنسان الخارق بيكون أخطر من الآلة الخارقة؟
الإنسان الخارق
إنسان خارق اللي يكون مدموج مع الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنا هذا، والله صراحة أميل له
صراحة أكثر من...
أنا ودي صراحة أنه نحافظ على هيمنتنا
شوف مثل ما قلت لك
يا أنك تكون أذكى منه، يا أنه يكون أذكى منك
بس الأهداف...
مشكلة موائمة الأهداف إلى الآن معقّدة
أكيد بنكون في الجانب الآمن إذا أنت
لا إله إلا الله
متفوق عليه
ما عندي مشكلة إذا كنت أذكى منه
أو إذا كان أذكى منك بس في صفك
أشعر إذا اندمجت معه بيصير يضرني أكثر
بتصير عندك مخاطر أكثر، لو اندمجت معه
وصرت إنسان خارق؛ بتصير مخاطرك أكثر من الآلة
لأن أنت جزء منها أصلًا
إيه، فالآلة ما تقدر تقضي عليك
لأنها بتقضي على نفسها
هذا على الأقل نقطة حلوة
بس بتقضي عليك في نفس الوقت
بس ما عندها دافع أنها تقضي على نفسها
إيه، بس أنت مو هي؛ أنت جزء آخر
عندك الآلة أقوى
إيه، فاحنا نصممها بحيث أنه يكون ما في فرق
وتراك أنت الآن مندمج مع الآلة
شوف أنا وياك لابسين ساعة أبل
وكنا نتكلم عن استخدام التقنية
ودائمًا أضرب مثال
أقول تخيل أنت مثلًا جيت وقست الـ «آي كيو» حقك
وطلع مثلًا 120
وجيت نقّصت من الـ«آي كيو» حقك عشر درجات
بيضعف أدائك في حياتك اليومية طبعًا، صح وللا لا؟
خلني برجع العشر نقاط؛ بس بسحب جوالك وأجهزتك
بيضعف أدائك
أنت الأدوات التقنية هذه تقعد تتخيلها
أول الكمبيوتر كان كبر الغرفة، صار كبر المكتب
صار كبر الجيب، صار في الساعة
بكرة «إيلون ماسك» بدأ يدخله جوّا المخ
فاحنا بالفعل مندمجين مع الآلة
بس أجهزة خارجية، ما بعد صارت داخلية
وقاعدة ترى تزيد من ذكائك وأنت ما تدري
يعني الذكاء ترى مو بثابت
حتى اللي الناس تسوي «آي كيو»
الـ«آي كيو» حقه ثمانين اليوم
يعتبر ذكي قبل 100 سنة
لأن معدل الـ«آي كيو» قاعد يزيد مع الوقت
يزيد مع التعليم، يزيد مع الاهتمام بالصحة
مع استخدام التقنية
بكرة اللي احنا نعتبره ذكي الحين؛ بيصير صعوبات تعلم
صدق والله
مثل ما الحين اللي صعوبات تعلم هنا
ترى كان طبيعي قبل
والله والتحدي
هل كان فيه نقطة ودك أنه تكلمنا فيها وما تكلمنا فيها؟
والله كان فيه نقطة
إيه الأخلاقيات فيه ثلاثة أوجه
يمكن ناقشنا ثنتين منها
وحدة، كيف نستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي بطريقة أخلاقية؟
فيه اللي كيف احنا نعامل الذكاء الاصطناعي بطريقة أخلاقية؟
موضوع الأنسنة والوعي
لأن كلها مرتبطة بالوعي
الموضوع الثاني، كيف الذكاء الاصطناعي يعامل البشر بأخلاقية؟
يعني كيف تبرمج الأخلاق في الآلة؟
هذه ترجع لـ -لا إله إلا الله- اللي يمكن ناقشنا جزء منها
في مبادئ «ستيوارت راسل»
اللي قال واحدة منها: أنه خلاص ما تقول له أيش الأخلاق
أنت خلّه يتعلم الأخلاق من بيئته
يحاول يتعلمها من الإنسان
فكذا تلقى الروبوت اللي في السعودية
أخلاقه غير أخلاق اللي...
مثلًا تعطيه القهوة باليسار؛ يعطيك النظرة اللي...
الروبوت اللي في اليابان تلقاه مرة محترم وقته وكذا
والمشكلة في هذه
يعني قد تقول حل، بس لو أنك قدرت تبني الشيء هذا
قبل 100 سنة أو 200 سنة
كان الروبوت بيتعلم من الاستعباد
عادي
وبرضه كان ممكن يتعلم
أن مثلًا ناس من أعراق معينة؛ أقل الإنسانية
وحتى الأنثى كانت تعتبر أقل الإنسانية
فهذه مشكلة
كيف أنك الحين تقول للروبوت أيش الأخلاق؟
إيه تخيل الحين أمريكا هي اللي تصنعها
فهي اللي تحدد الأخلاق
بالضبط
مشكلة
بالضبط، الحين حتى «شات جي بي تي»
قال عنه «إيلون ماسك»
«استيقظ»
شوي يساري هو، التريبة لأن هو ساكن في «وادي السيلكون»
كيف تضمن أنه يتصرف بطريقة أخلاقية؟
عشان أوريك حجم مشكلة بناء ذكاء اصطناعي آمن
عشان تحلّه؛ لازم تحل معضلة الأخلاق
اللي لها ألاف سنين
هذا على قولتهم شرط
هذه مسألة فلسفية بحتة
بالضبط، كأني أقولك
تمام، بنبني ذكاء اصطناعي آمن
أول خطوة، يلا خلنا نحل الأخلاق يا شباب
اللي ما انحلت لها ألاف السنين
فهذه مشكلة ثانية
كيف أنك تبرمج الذكاء الاصطناعي يكون يعني...
ولا فيه حل يرضي الجميع في النهاية
فيه تحدي والله
الذكاء الاصطناعي مشكلة
أنت من جد تتوقع أن قوقل عندها شيء
أفضل من «أوبن إيه آي» بس ماهي قادرة تطلقه
وللا هي ما تعرف أصلًا؟
لا، أنا أعتقد أن هذا أفضل شيء طلعوه
هذا أفضل شيء؟
هم سيئين إلى هذا الدرجة؟
فيه وصفة سحرية كتبوها «أوبن إيه آي»
ما أدري أيش هي صراحة
فيه شيء اللي قالوا ما أعلنا عنه
«جيمني» هو اسمه وللا قوقل؟
قالوا: شيء جالسين نشتغل عليه
بيكون هو النقلة النوعية الظاهر اسمه «جيمني»
والله أتمنى ما يمنعونه على السريع
على الأقل نجربه والله
عشان كذا أقول ضروري ندخل في التقنية دي
وما نقعد معتمدين على...
هو مشكلتها بس توفر بيانات برضه في السعودية
أو حتى عربي
يعني ما في بيانات كفاية تتدرب عليها الآلات وللا؟
يبغى لك ترقمنها
يمكن موجودة كثيرة في الكتب
وهل هي بصيغة تقدر...
هذا شيء ثاني بعد يرفع الضغط
يعني قوقل والشركات هذه قاعدين
يستغلوننا احنا وكل العالم
أننا ندرب نماذجهم
أنا وياك دربنا قوقل، كل يوم ندربه
لما تدخل يقولك: اختار أيش السيارة
وبكرة لما يخلصون؛ يقولك أخلاقيات
وليش أعطيك إياها؟
وأنا جالس أدربه لي ستين يوم
مع كل تسجيل دخول
بالضبط، قبل كان يوريك كلمتين
ألا
يقول اكتبهم
أو حتى الأحرف... إيه إلا
إيه كلمتين يقولك اكتبهم
هو ترى فعليًا فيه كلمة يعرفها والثانية لا
الثانية هذه أنت اللي تعلمه
عشان يروح يدرب النموذج حقه
عشان يرقمن كل الكتب
اللي بعد ما خلّص رقمنة وقضى
درب نماذجه
بعد لما تجي تقول عطني
يبدأ يقول لك...
أنا شفت في تويتر قبل كم يوم
وزارة العدل حطت مشروع اسمه رقمنة أو شيء مثل كذا
بس الظاهر أنهم يدفعون لك فلوس عشان تسويها
فهم أرشفوا المستندات؛ بس يبغونك تأكدها...
فتلقى مكتوب 182 مثلًا
هو يبغاك تكتبها
يعطونك فلوس على كل مرة تخلص الظاهر حاجة
لو يستخدمونها ويخلونها في تسجيل الدخول للمنصات الحكومية
يوفرون عليهم ويوفرون علينا
ياخذون كل المستندات حقهم
يحطها وخله ما يدخّل إلا...
بالضبط، أنا ناديت فيه من زمان
وأنا بكون أسعد واحد لما أشوف شيء على الأقل
مدام أنا بدخل وبسوي تسجيل دخول
بدل ما أدرب قوقل؛ أدرب نموذج محلي
أنا في الأخير بدرب أحد
أدرب على الأقل نماذج محلية
وفيه الدائرة، وفيه المكتبة الوطنية
يعني فيه الناس يحتاجون تدريب على المستندات العربية القديمة
فاحنا يبغى لنا نرقمن جزء كبير
من البيانات اللي موجودة عندنا على الأقل بالعربي
ممكن نتفوق عليهم على الأقل من ناحية
بدل ما تصير أقل 0.5% تصير يعني...
جزئية العربية هذه أكثر كثير
فتصير أنت ذكي في هذا المجال
وخصوصًا حتى ما تدري يمكن تصير في مجال خاص فيهم
إذا أنت علمته على العربي
ما عندهم وصول على البيانات هذه، صح؟
إيه، بس فيه مشكلة بالعربي
أن نوعية المعرفة بعد هنا وهنا
يعني أغلب العلوم مثلًا الطبيعية
حتى العرب ينشروه بالإنقليزي
بس قصدي إذا أخذت أنت كل التراث
لأن ما عندهم التراث العربي
فما أدري إذا بيفرق في معرفة الآلة
إذا أضفت التراث كله
لأنه أصلًا حتى مو موجود على الإنترنت
فصار يفتي
والله يفتي الحين صراحة
إيه هو يفتي الحين الصدق
أي معنى تقصد يفتي؟
لا لا، فيه تطبيق مسوينه الظاهر آيفون إسلام أو شيء
فتوى
عجيب
بدل الآلة
أنت شايف الحين الحملات
اللي خلك حريص، والناس اللي يكلمون أجانب
وأنا بنك «الراجحي»
فيجيك واحد جنسية مختلفة
حتى ما يعرف عربي
يأتمت الرسالة، بحيث أنه حتى لما توصلك رسالة
توصلك حتى يمكن يقولك يا أبو عمر
إيه
وسهل أنه يقدر يعرف عنك كل شيء
ترى لو تبحث عن أي أحد
حتى لو كان مو موجود على الإنترنت مرة
تقدر تعرف عنه كثير ترى من الإنترنت
إيه يدخل على ملفك في تويتر
إيه لولاه، فيه ناس تعتقد أن حضورهم على الإنترنت قليل
مثلًا يجي يقول أنا اللي موجود في كل مكان مثلًا
بس فيه واحد تلقى عنده
بس شوي، وما يدخل الانترنت واجد
فهو يتوقع أن ما عنده «آثار خطوات» كثيرة في الإنترنت
لو تبحث والله تلقى أنك تعرف عنه
أكثر مما يتوقع
أنا قد سويت تجربة قبل
فيه ناس في تويتر مو فعالين
تقدر تعرف هو يتابع مين، ومن ما يتابعه
بس مجرد متابعات
حتى لو ما تكتب
أنت مين تتابع ومين يتابعك؟
أقدر أستنتج شيء عنك
صح؟
وأنك ساكن بس تراقب بصمت
بس مجرد لك حساب
وحددت كم واحد تتابعه
وكم واحد عرفك وتابعك؛ هذا كافي
على قولتك البصمة هذه، البصمة الرقمية
يقدر الذكاء الاصطناعي يستنبط منها أشياء كثيرة
تخيل أوه! يا سيدي